And one of the big things, maybe the biggest thing is a massive
allegation against Andrew Tate that we knew about on this stream.
We've actually mentioned on this stream about this in like 2020.
What's the accusation that Andrew Tate Lauren Southern right
now? It's kind of like it's kind of like I'm going to do an analogy.
Okay. It's kind of like the Ethan Klein thing. All right. Just
because you think is natural or something you're a woman doesn't
mean people can you. All right. That's not a like just cuz you
have like really really anti-woman views doesn't mean you're
a fair target. Okay, that you you don't get to be a fair there's
nothing in the world that can make you a fair target. Tax forms
and right after all of this I think she's saying he did all of
this and people still worshiped him. So I have spite for these
people, right? I have a lot of spite for the people who worshiped
this guy despite him basically platforming exactly who he was.
Lauren Southern today took to Twitter to announce her new book.
She got a new book. Okay, she got a new book and it talks about,
you know, right-wing media like that, right-wing media and some
of the she went through being in right-wing media. And one of
the big things, maybe the biggest thing is a massive allegation
against Andrew Tate that we knew about on this stream. We've
actually mentioned on this stream that's kind of been talked
about by a lot of people over time.
>> Any else copy the book? I'm not going to get the book,
but uh I do like appreciate the allegation coming out. It's very
late and there are maybe some criticisms of it coming out this
late, but I'll I'll probably read and see what her reasoning
is before trying to make any criticisms. I would say
Rolo tweets showing backup about this. Oh, sure, dude. There's
uh there is like contemporaneous evidence. This has been mentioned
for quite a while, right? Her cameraman went live or not went
live, sorry, her cameraman was on Twitter drunk apparently and
posted about this in like 2020.
What's the accusation that Andrew Tate Lauren Southern right
now I think probably the biggest question you know if you're
if you're going to be critical okay so if you're going to be
critical in like an intellectually honest way you might have
some criticism for like why did this wait have to wait until
her career as a conservative influencer died completely to come
out like maybe this should have been something that came out
earlier I tend not to like I you got to let victims go at their
own pace right so so it is what it is that's probably the criticism
that I mean, dude, there's a lot of criticism though. There are
people getting very mad. Okay, Mr. Andrew Wilson was one of the
people who uh Lauren Southern was not by Andrew Tate. How the
is anybody enough to believe this? It's like I don't think I
think this is one of his first tweets about it. I'm like, wait,
did you look at the did you look at the article or did you tweet
this and then you like started looking into it? Oh, this is a
this is a good question. I asked I asked a question of Andrew
Wilson as I didn't want to be like, "Oh, you're you're so full
of with this, right?" So, I just asked like, "How's your opinion
change with contemporaneous, you know, medical reports, police
reports, this kind of thing?" This is why she didn't say anything.
Well, it was because she was a right-wing influencer, right?
And a lot of right-wing people will naturally just say, "This
is not real." All right.
You kids, right-wing influencers go, "Actually, I think they're
just trying to make sure we can all move on and heal as Americans."
You adults, sorry, you kids, that's what right-wing influencers
say. you adults. They're like, "No, no, that didn't happen. That
didn't happen at all." Dude, I wonder if they were so about transing
the kid cuz the trans people were getting in on their territory.
Not that trans people are, but they believe they were. Right.
Rightwingers believe trans trans people were and they're like,
"Huh, that's my that's my market. You disgusting." Andrew confidently
asserts things out of ignorance all the time. That's how he debates.
Uh,
I've not necessarily seen that. I think he will take calculated
risks and do some stuff like that, but they save
No, that's straight up what I think it is at this point, honestly.
So, Apothe Prophet asks, "How do you know that?" He responds,
"Because I've interviewed other victims of her ridiculous false
accusations before. That's how." So, I don't know if he's talking
about Rolo here or who. Let's see. Let's see if there's a response.
Like, you care about victims when you mock and revel in the abuse
and leaking of other women just because you disagree with their
lifestyle and you personally pile on the uh their online harassment.
Examples is going to be Pixie, right? I have a major one. Yes.
and it completely rubbed me the wrong way about you. Well, no.
The example would literally be Pixie, right? This this literally
is Pixie. And we can just go to his like,
"Ew, Pixie tweet on like November 26th when those videos got
leaked." He like tweeted about it
>> A prostate profit. Gross. I mean, the example is clearly
pixie here. I think Andrew might not understand that it's like
um
that this guy's saying like leaks specifically. Anyway, I saw
the Andrew Wilson tweet and I was just like, "Dude, I don't think
you looked at like what her what she said, which is particularly
jarring because she actually went ahead and she'll say her exact
reasoning here." Yeah. Hi all. Some last notes before I log off.
I've decided to release a few chapters of this book for free,
specifically those involving Andrew Tate and his ongoing criminal
cases. Let me address a few things before you get into said chapters.
So she actually took the Andrew Wil or so the not Andrew Wilson,
the Andrew Tate stuff and she made it free and put it online
because she knew that that was going to be the the source of
controversy for this. So she actually made those chapters free.
So you could actually see what evidence she has or what evidence
she claims to have and you could like you know come up with some
hypothetical about it. But I think Andrew just like immediately
tweeted lie this lying as did a lot of people.
Well, so pensive goat, that was going to be my question if I
actually kept, you know, conversing with Andrew on the topic.
I I I don't think I replied again, but I asked him, he replied
to me and didn't understand my question or didn't read my question
correctly, but uh I was asking him like, "Oh, how would your
opinion change with contemporaneous medical or police reports?"
And he basically said, "Oh, well, it could change." And I'm like,
"Well, I asked how it would change, not could it change." I know
it could change, but
>> uh we'll get into that. Stephen Jellian, we are going
to get into that as a part of the show. I'm just getting around
I'm getting to some of the discussion and like positions that
seem to clearly be getting taken without people reading it at
all. Right? Like all I would say is and I this is probably why
I suck at Twitter. Okay. My first my first inclination when I
heard about this was, "Oh man, I should read that before I even
go live on stream so I don't say something." Right? But these
people are like, "I'm going to make a public statement with my
personal account before I read any of it." Which to me is just
like, okay, that's a little that's a little much. This happened
in 2018. I believe the the actual assault happened in 2018. Uh
Lauren doesn't go into graphic detail about it, but she implies
that it's that's what it is. His blood sports debate style prevents
him from ever getting a worthwhile debate opponent too, but it
is interesting or entertaining. Sorry. Is anybody enough to believe
Andrew Wilson? Well, it's not about believing him. Like this
is clearly this is like rage bait, right? This is like rage bait
and he'll defend this tweet. He's like, I think he's like rolling
dice here and saying I can defend this. I won't look totally
if I say this. Right.
>> And realistically, who is if he was totally wrong here?
Let's say Lauren Southern went to the police. She has like three
different police reports, two different medical reports that
all support the idea that she was probably honor about the date
she met Andrew Tate, right? Let's say she had all of that. Would
Andrew Wilson lose like a single follower? Would he lose a single
follower for having tweeted this? I think all of like a huge
part of his follow base would be people who go like yeah w Andrew
and then they would never care about any corrections right on
this
>> That's not to say that um Andrew can't defend his ideas
or Andrew is like a [__] I don't believe that. I'm
just saying that like I don't think there's anybody who really
follows him who would like me I'm out. Not by and large. Remember
when Andrew Wilson beat Dave Smith by proving Dave isn't a real
libertarian? Yep. That was a very embarrassing debate for Dave
Smith. It's a horrible debate for Dave Smith. His audience seems
like the she was asking for it type.
Some of them sure anybody who's picked up from like the whatever
manosphere stuff. I would maybe they could be like that. I'd
say it's more they're like the completely unreasonable
burden of proof expectation and burden of proof people where
they're like you got to prove it. It's like what do you need
need like a doctor's video of them like extracting Andrew Andrew
Tate's like seed from her? Is that what you need to prove this?
That's what they need, right? That's the level. That's They're
like, "That's what proof is." It's like, "Okay, that's probably
never happening. Let's be real." He said Pixie was asking for
it. Uh, yeah, he did. Anyway, so we can we we'll look into a
lot of this stuff. I'm trying to think of if I want to. So, we'll
read her tweet her tweet and then maybe we read the entire like
set of chapters in the post here and then after this, how long
is this? This is not that much. Okay. I think it's just this
this chapter by Andrew Tate. So, so we'll uh we'll look into
this. And then there's an actual justice warrior. So, actual
justice warrior is a close friend. It seems like he might have
coordinated with Lauren around this release to put a video out
giving his opinion and his backing of her and her evidence. So,
from what I've heard, I haven't watched his video yet, but from
what I've heard, he basically says, "I've seen the evidence around
this and I'm putting my reputation on that." So, cool. It's already
a onestar review on Amazon. Horrible. Okay. All right. We read
this part. The reason these chapters aren't behind a payw wall
is because they weren't written with the intention of profiting
off of this incident. They were written because they're part
of my story and they're true. If you're here just to just to
read about Tate or think uh this is some kind of selling point,
please don't buy the book. If you won't find anything more significant
about him or sorry, you won't find anything more significant
about him in its pages beyond what's already here for free. I
can assure you no one is more aware of the cosmic irony or colossal
train wreck of my life than I am. I've made mistakes, some mine
alone, others shaped by the psychological toll of existing in
a deeply toxic political space. If you're here to point those
things out, you're late. I've already written the book. I've
named the skeletons. You stupid. You hung out with the misogynist
so you get what you deserve. And she's like, "Yeah, that's part
of the book. That's literally that's like the thesis of the book
actually is like I feel like an idiot for ever believing in these
ideas or that these people really sincerely believe these ideas."
Who is this? This is Lauren Southern. Yeah. But I just I find
it very funny that it's like that's a that's a good way of putting
it. It's like yeah that's like the thesis. It's very much the
same as like the people who would criticize that or point that
out are very much the same as Lance from the surfs, right? It's
like hey maybe instead of just criticizing before reading you
just read understand a little bit and speak from an informed
perspective or you know ask the other don't just say like don't
say things that are that are basically totally disproven by the
core thesis of what the other person has to say or what their
general like belief is right it's like you're not even having
a conversation at that point if you're if you're going to ignore
the fact that they're saying something right and and basically
assert something that's totally contradicted about their opinions
it's totally contradicted by what they're saying then don't have
the conversation. It's like pointless. When Southern is the one
I do actually feel bad for in the end. Uh yeah, I mean it sounds
like she got into this really early. I'm sure the book will get
into it that she was like quite young when she started and then
she sort of like she kept developing these ideas was making a
lot of money and it was difficult to say like no no this is where
the line is. I'm sure there's a lot of that. I'd hope there's
a lot of like accountability taking too, right? She said some
things that are pretty offensive to a lot of people. Hopefully
there's some accountability taking there as well. see how it
is uh how easy it would be to convince yourself Tate is false
being falsely accused in that space.
Well, I think it's just the the unreasonable expectation of proof,
right? Like basically Andrew Tate has like a whole bunch of other
allegations, crime allegations.
He's got oh, what is it? He's got all of that and a bunch of
the contemporaneous evidence and a bunch of apparently supporting
evidence around this supports the idea that this happened. I
don't know exactly what Lauren saved and I don't think she's
she may never publish it publicly, right? But it does seem like
there are some there's like a decent amount of proof that's gotten
other influencers to come out and say actually I stand behind
her 100% on this. This definitely happened. She was like 17 when
she started out. She was young. I know 22 is like when she got
really heavily involved, but I did think she was like quite young
when she started like in media. Anyway, we we should keep reading.
Uh so you're here to point those things out. You're late. I've
already written the book. I've named the skeletons, told the
stories, own my mess. But let's be clear, my personal drama doesn't
change the credibility of claims I've made. I hope those who
can think for themselves can see past the name calling and attempts
to muddy the water that will certainly come about by influencers
for hire trying to cash in or cover their asses. I was not the
first person to talk about this event publicly. Others involved
chose to speak out and purvey a distorted version of these events,
not just to get ahead of the narrative, but to undermine other
witnesses and other legitimate cases of assault and trafficking.
I've spent much of my life since then mentally avoiding this
experience and the drama surrounding it, but I cannot remain
silent when my story is being twisted and used as a tool to discredit
others. It would be unjust not to set the record straight. I
don't know all of what she means here, but I do know there's
Tommy Robinson speaking about this where Tommy Robinson like
totally tries to discount her story. Um, yeah, it's like his
I guess his like he basically says that the next morning he met
up with Andrew Tate and Lauren and that they were still loveydvey
the next morning. I don't know if that's true. It's pretty difficult.
Milo too, maybe. Yeah, Milo's called her out as well. That's
true. I've got some other articles about it. We'll read about
the older allegations as well. Okay. Four. I understand people
will want evidence for some of the claims being made here, and
that's completely fair given the deeply personal nature of the
material. I've shared it privately with two media sources, one
mainstream and one left-leaning, the other independent and right-leaning.
I did this knowing readers have different levels of trust in
different outlets and wanted to offer a chance for clarity. So
independent right-wing I believe this is actual justice warrior
and we'll watch his video probably after we read the article.
I did this knowing readers have different levels of trust in
different outlets and wanted to offer a chance for clarity through
whichever lens they find more credible. I'll hyperlink their
pieces when I get a chance may take a few days. I haven't done
any interviews and don't plan to. If anyone else seems unusually
informed, no it's not some grand matrix conspiracy. Just a few
DMs and some advanced copies in the mail. And while this is my
account, it's not the only one. Another book by someone who knows
the sto this story from a very different angle is on the way.
Okay, I don't know what that means necessarily, but I mentioned
on these pages that I've assisted with investigations where where
and when I could. Through much of uh sorry, though for much of
my life, I stayed on the sidelines out of fear and a desire to
preserve my anonymity. Since that's no longer an issue, I want
to make it clear that I'm willing to help in any way I can in
a more official capacity, especially with the ongoing cases in
Romania and elsewhere if they would like to reach out to me.
This is something that I assume would be like complex and difficult
to deal with is knowing that you have the ability to help people
or you have the ability to give testimony that lends credence
to their own testimony and you sit back because you want to remain
anonymous. I would imagine that is something that probably
gets at people over time. Uh she was 22 apparently Ozel saying
22 when she um when she was assaulted. Uh I've seen the claims
online that many of the anonymous witnesses don't exist or that
they've been paid off or are part of some deep state plot. every
kind of misdirection imaginable. I don't know any of these women
personally, but I do know that I exist and I know that no one
paid me to come forward. Everything in the book and here is written
in my own words and published by me. No ghostriters, no sponsors,
no shady backers, just hundreds of hours of my time and more
sleepless nights than I care to count. I don't know if the legal
cases will be successful. I assume she means against Andrew Tate.
What I do know is that in a world where you can buy off algorithms
and politicians, the truth is hard to find and it certainly isn't
always officially verified. As we've just seen recently with
Epstein, or sorry, as we've just seen recently with Epstein,
information is a p is powerful, though. The more people who understand
the digital delusion we're living in, the closer we get to breaking
it. I know parts of the book I've written will be used as political
bludgeons in in the culture war. I know it'll be chopped into
clip uh sorry, clickbait,
stripped of context, and turned into ammo for people who haven't
even read a page. The point, of course, is that in the chaos,
maybe it will find its way to the handful of people trying to
get out of this digital hall of mirrors.
or to even fewer who still actually read books or to the even
fewer who still actually read books. My ultimate hope with the
publication of these chapters and more importantly sorry and
more importantly with my full book is for healing even for those
who have hurt me. I've learned well in my own life that he some
healing only comes from purifying fire. I hope my care in writing
these notes and chapters give the truth uh the best chance to
breathe in a media ecosystem that thrives on distortion and unreality.
Let's see if it makes it out alive. Okay,
so here's the stuff from the actual book. Wait, did we see We
didn't see ellipsies here, did we? Oh, boy. This day Laguna is
everywhere. Let's move it up. You know, this is pretty long,
right? Didn't seem that long. Oh, never mind. It does seem that
long. Oh, we might have to break this up a little bit. Oh, boy.
Yeah, we might have to break this up a little bit. I for some
reason I looked at it earlier and I was like, it's not that bad.
I can get through it pretty easy. Put into chat GPT. Why? You
literally You're sitting here. You have somebody who will read
this whole thing to you. What do you mean put it into chat? GPT.
[__] are you talking about, bro? [__]
you talking about, bro? I'm literally just going to read it to
you. You don't have to do anything. You just put your headphones
in and listen.
>> One sec.
>> I don't read slow. I just don't read at like 1.8 time
speed or two times speed, whatever you'd be using uh used to
reading at, I guess, or hearing audiobooks at. I read pretty
fast to be honest with you. Read it in Steven Fry's voice, please.
Gross. put it into the AIS. No, shut up. Although, I heard Grock
has like a voice mode now. I do just want like uh if I just had
a thing that like while I was working out, I could ask it questions
and it's reasonably good at answering the questions. Could you
imagine? Could you imagine how good that would be? I'd pay I'd
pay a I'd probably pay 100 bucks a month for something that basically
functioned as like chat GPT Google with voice in and out and
and yeah I' I'd probably pay like if it was like good and could
read well like could read me articles well it's like hey I heard
this happened today could you find me an article and just read
me the article in this
get me out to read all of it that seems unreasonable okay chapter
introduction about crime in the digital aid has been age has
been cuten and George were Tommy and I's mutual video team at
the time referencing earlier chapters
Okay. Cheapy GP. Okay. Iotech.
Okay. Enemy girl voice assistant would go kind of crazy. Good.
Well, that's the nice thing about Grock is like the things I
would use it for. Like I could use it for research before stream,
right? I could just be like, "Hey,
like here's some here's some topics I'm looking for. Can you
give me like some popular tweets around this?" And then it should
be able to go scan Twitter, right? I think Grock's like tapped
into Twitter. Totally. Yes. Seems like a pretty good competitive
advantage. Anyway, I'm not entirely sure how the conversations
leading up to it went, and part of me dreads how sinister they
may have been, but around February 2018, Tommy Robinson mentioned
to Ken, George, and me that we had been in contact with some
wealthy crypto investors in Eastern Europe who might be interested
in sponsoring a larger media project we could all build together.
Things are were going incredibly well with my YouTube views,
but as any upand cominging online influencer knows, you can never
just be okay with things. You're always chasing the next big
idea, the next big project, the next opportunity. a right-wing
European media outlet hosted by some of the most famous figures
in the dissident, right? It sounded crazy, but with the right
funding, maybe it could work. How could I say no? O, we're getting
uh we're getting some previews of how we end up getting to uh
Tenant Media in the
The flights were booked almost instantly by the investors, and
I'll never forget showing up to the airport in Luton with Ken
and George early in the morning. Tommy was off his head as usual,
but I wasn't familiar enough with the antics of addicts to fully
understand the gravity of it. He wore a matching designer tracksuit,
a typical look, and kept clenching his jaw, motormouthing between
paranoid rants and overly enthusiastic anticipation. He somehow
smuggled an absurd amount of through airport security, incredibly
cheeky about it as always. Now, I know the TSA and every equivalent
agency is largely nothing more than a time-wasting joke. But
back then, I still clung to the illusion that airport security
actually served a purpose. Watching Tommy slip into the plane's
bathroom again and again to do lines left me in a surreal state.
It felt like I was living on air autopilot, watching a movie
I didn't understand. One that was way longer than my uh that
sorry, one that was no longer my story but someone else's. I've
heard every motivational podcast about taking extreme responsibility
for your life. And maybe in a twisted way, I tried to avoid responsibility
by taking my hands off the wheel entirely as if I had no role
in the truck flying off the cliff. My peopleleasing passive self
had no business being on a plane unsupervised with a coke up
Tommy on route to some shady meeting in Eastern Europe. But there
I was nodding along to every unhinged plan like it made perfect
sense. Honestly, I was just as bad as Tommy only I didn't need
to feel my delusions. He was probably doing drugs because he
knew how insane everything was. I was worse. I actually thought
it was serious. I was sitting there mentally drafting business
talking points wondering if we needed a Google Doc slideshow.
Guys, do we have a plan here? Anytime I asked about the investors,
the answers were vague and broken. Something about a professional
boxer or whatever. Why a boxer in Eastern Europe would want to
invest in our company is beyond me. But sure, they'd paid they'd
paid for the flights and agreed to a meeting. What's the worst
that could happen? Okay, we keep looking. What's the worst that
could
What? Oh, sorry. When we landed in Romania, Tommy told us that
the inves the investors had sent cars. We're going to love these
bloss chirped still buzzing while the rest of us were groggy
from the morning flight. He grabbed our bags and headed for the
airport. I traveled through enough of Europe, including the old
Eastern block to be familiar with the dreary landscapes and brutalist
architecture.
But the people waiting for us were hard to miss. They stood out
like sore thumbs against the washed out Balkan backdrop and the
aging Dashia supernovas from 2001.
Two sharply dressed men leaned against polished sports cars,
waving as we rolled our suitcases down the walkway. The cars
looked comically out of place and completely impractical for
our luggage. But I wasn't ever I wasn't about to complain. At
least our investors clearly had money. And I'd never ridden a
car like that before. Tommy clased hands with his acquaintances
in one of those firm pull-in handshakes that turned into a quick
backpack half hug. The kind that was more about respect than
warmth. As it turned out, there the pair were brothers. And after
the greeting, they ushered us into the cars. So obviously the
Tates, but not before making it clear that I would personally
be personally escorted by a man named Andrew. He had a wide grin
and a unique lisp that reminded me of an old childhood friend,
but seemed a bit too eager to get me alone. I figured we were
all headed to the same place anyway, and Ken, George, and Tommy
all knew where I was and who I was with. Andrew seemed harmless
enough, maybe even a fan, I didn't want to overthink it. Before
I'd even finished buckling my seat belt, he was telling me how
much he liked my work.
Gross. I won't pretend I remember exactly how the conversation
went, but Andrew clearly viewed me as some kind of hero, someone
saving the Western world. He'd watched plenty of my content.
He referenced it almost reverently. Between flirtatious smiles
and compliments, he was nice, charming even. And I won't lie,
I wasn't exactly disappointed to get a break from Tommy's antics
and have a conversation with someone who was actually sober.
Tommy mentioned he needed a nap before our meeting with the investors
that evening. He needed much more than a nap. So, after we stopped
at the hotel, Andrew asked if I was hungry and if he could take
me to grab an early dinner before we meet up at the compound
later. The sun was still high. We had plenty of time to, so I
said yes without thinking. I wasn't in the habit of turning down
food. Years of financial stress made me frugal to a fault. My
travels around Europe were basically a McDonald's tour, something
my friends constantly teased me about. The steakhouse Andrew
took me to was a stark departure from my usual dining choices.
I' I'd say it was upscale, but everything seemed fancy compared
to my chicken nugget dinners. We really did get along, but seeing
someone with so much apparent wealth and success, I found myself
curious about his ultimate life goals or ultimate goals in life.
Date Brothers carried themselves like they own the place, well-dressed,
fit, with nice cars and enough money to start an entire news
organization.
I don't know if I was slowly waking up from my dopamine induced
haze, but part of me was just not satisfied with with what I
was seeing or where I was going. If I built a news network, if
I got more fame, if I got more wealth, what was that? What was
it all for? I wanted to know where this was headed. I can't help
but laugh at the way I used to question men. They'd confidently
declare their plans to dominate their field or conquer the world.
And I would simply stare into their eyes and ask, "But why? For
what? What does this do for your soul?" I'd watch something in
them crack something I didn't understand yet.
Okay. Ah, I got some got some weird ass weirdass comments in
the chat. I'm glad you guys are enjoying. But also, can you guys
chill? Don't. She gave it up for unlimited bread sticks is an
inappropriate comment when discussing somebody in the prelude
to their insult or dinglingness. Okay, very strange. She went
from getting paid by the Tates to paid by the Russians. I don't
believe they were paid by the Tates. I don't believe this Tate
deal went through. Yeah, I'm not sure that this ever went through
or became something. Okay, really? I asked them those questions
because they were the same ones I was asking myself. Some part
of me hoped the successful men would have the answer, >> but
I hadn't. Thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> So, hold on. Some part of me hoped that these successful
men would have the answer, but I hadn't yet realized that part
of the journey up meant taking those kinds of questions and lining
them up against a wall for execution without trial. Looking back,
it's clear Andrew humored a lot of my queries, especially about
whether he wanted to start a family or get married someday. If
I found the right woman, of course, I was going to start trying
to do a British accent, but it would be disastrous. That's what
life is all about, family. It's how we rebuild Western civilization,
he mused. But he lingered on that if just a little too long for
it to feel sincere. There was an awkwardness in his response,
like he was nervous I might see through it. Um,
I'm going to try to make a choice here. I I think um a lot of
people like probably would tie this back to somebody else who
was with Lauren Southern. I think it'd be kind of disrespectful
to, you know, bring other stuff into this. I think I'll just
try to read this as dispassionately as I can without, you know,
making snide references to people I dislike. Yeah, I think that's
the appropriate thing to do here. So, I understand there's some
jokes I could probably get in here, but uh I'm I'm going to refrain,
okay? Cuz it just seems like the appropriate thing to do. There
was an awkwardness in his response. Like, he was nervous. I might
see through it. I remember this part of our conversation well,
and it was the first moment that things felt off. I hadn't learned
to spot red flags yet. at least not the kind that wore nice clothes,
smiled politely, and echoed your politics back to you like a
mirror. Dinner had relaxed me more than it should have. It was
almost a rehearsed level of calm. You never said anything wrong,
and maybe that was a red flag. That maybe that was the red flag.
After the meal, we returned to the hotel to prepare for the investment
meeting. I didn't know what I was expecting the meeting to look
like, but it certainly wasn't what I found myself walking into.
With Call and George, Tommy, and I loaded into sports cars, Andrew
and his brother Tristan drove us through the dreary side streets
of a Bucharest neighborhood, not far from our hotel. The final
destination didn't look like much at first, just a generic industrial
warehouse. But when the black metal giant black gate rolled open,
it revealed a scene that would have been obvious to me as a criminal
operation if I had any clue how the world worked. We were greeted
by glowing blue pools surrounded by luxury cars as we stepped
onto the tiled entrance.
>> Wait, I just came back. What happened is is actually
Lauren Southern saying she was written by Andrew Tate. Yes. Uh,
by the way, second, it's been referenced on stream multiple times.
This this allegation was made by her cameraman, the Kellin person
here, um, in 2020.
So, it's been known for like 5 years now. It's just not something
she wanted to prosecute. I think there's probably a large degree,
in my opinion, of like
preser self-preservation here, right? that you can't be the right-wing
woman who accuses like right-wing financeers of rape. I think
that was probably something that she thought about, something
that she considered and and didn't want to pursue this at the
time. I think she did try to pursue it with some criminal organizations.
Sorry, criminal some uh
crime organiz like some police. Okay. She tried to go to the
police in the UK, I'd heard, and in Canada, not in Romania because
>> So, she gets into it later. I believe she didn't go
to the police in Romania because she believed Andrew Tate's whole
cope about how I have the police wrapped around my finger, right?
>> I think that was I think she didn't file a police report
in Romania, unless I
She did go to I believe a doctor after they left Romania.
>> Anyway, the building itself looked as if it had been
designed by edgy Reddit mods and said anime nerds turned Marie
Condo
fanatics. A giant samurai statue was one of the few decorations
in the entryway, and flat screen TVs adorn the walls, flashing
cryptocurrency prices. It felt like every decision made here
was exactly what a 10-year-old would do if they suddenly became
a multi-millionaire. I want fancy cars, a glowing pool, a big
samurai statue, girls, and my favorite e celebrities.
What was more interesting than the decor, though, were pe the
people in the building. At this point, it was hard to tell who
was in charge. Was it the brothers or the nerdy-l lookinging
crypto bros sitting around a table on computers, eyes glued to
their investment screens? It almost seemed like the brothers
were the muscle and drivers while the crypto guys were the ones
doing the actual work. I was suddenly snapped out of my fascination
with the scenery by an overwhelming sense that something was
terribly wrong with Tommy. I'm not sure what it uh I'm not sure
he had even napped at all. He had look he had somehow gotten
more drugs or sorry, had he somehow gotten more drugs since landing
in Bucharest? It certainly looked that way. Call and George exchanged
concern uh concerned knowing glances as we watched Tommy lobb
one social grenade after another into what we'd hoped would be
a productive investment meeting. It was nothing short of a disaster.
It was beyond obvious to everyone in the room that they were
either speaking to se a severely mentally ill man or someone
inhabiting a completely different druginduced realm. Watching
the reaction of the main crypto bro was something I wish I could
describe in a way beyond writing. It's not a perfect comparison,
but imagine Donnie Azoff Jonah Hill in the Wolf of Wall Street
enduring Tommy's ramblings. Oh, okay. The whole scene felt straight
out of an SNL sketch. From the point from this point forward,
I'll call this guy Donnie.
What was even more fascinating, though, was that Tommy's behavior
had no apparent effect on the pitch being delivered from across
the table. Donnie pointed to one of the screens and confidently
announced that what appeared to be millions of dollars displayed
in green pixels was their coins making uh were was what their
coins were making in just the last 24 hours. I looked up the
screen as the numbers kept climbing, another $10,000 as I watched.
It was incomprehensible to me. We had just entered the era of
crypto scams collapsing, but it still hadn't fully settled into
the public's consciousness just how farreaching these pump and
dump schemes were. I didn't think I or many other influencers
at the time really understood all the altcoin jargon yet. My
head was spinning. Tommy chewing on nothing. Sorry, my head was
spinning. Tommy chewing on nothing. Call and George doing their
best to look engaged. And the tape brothers casually lounging
in their muscle shirts. I really wish I could remember the exact
name they pitched us. If I could, it would probably make you
laugh. But after an exhausting technical monologue, Donnie put
his hands on the table, looked up, and said, "Well, we'll call
it Freedom Token or some nonsense like that." "Oh, no." I thought,
"They want us to sell cryptocurrency.
Is this even an investment meeting at all?" Despite my growing
realization, I still wanted to make something out of all of this.
I had nothing to lose at this point. So, I interrupted rather
awkwardly. The coin stuff is really interesting, but do you plan
on putting an initial investment into this media company we're
starting? Or is this going to be entirely a crypto operation?
The men at the table seemed caught off guard, but Donnie quickly
scrambled to reassure me. Absolutely. If we can come to an agreement,
we'd offer the initial operating cost to the news network and
link this token to it, making it mutually beneficial for everyone.
Honestly, the token will be something all patriots can get behind.
It'll just be a side operation, more of a way for your viewers
to earn by sharing and engaging with your content. barely the
focus of the project. Plus, we'd give you all the shares of the
token for your own benefit. All sorry, we'd give you all shares
of the token for your own benefit. Great, I responded just before
he cut me off by launching into another incomprehensible tirade
about crypto jargon. Crypto bros are great at this. It's like
half the battle is just confusing you enough that you're too
embarrassed to ask for details. To be honest, I didn't care about
the money at all. I was delusionally invested in building this
alternative media empire and I might have been the only one in
the room still under the misguided impression that this was the
real purpose of the meeting. I wasn't thrilled about the crypto
angle, but it seemed like we might be able to make something
work if they were genuinely interested in contributing a few
hundred grand upfront. Just as I started running through the
possibilities in my head, Tommy took the conversational reigns
again and almost instantly destroyed any serious credibility.
I'd managed to salvage uh sorry I'd managed to salvage with my
admittedly naive but critical questions. Sorry, I need to read
that sentence again. That was a that was a doozy. Just as I started
running through the possibilities in my head, Tommy took the
conversational reigns again and almost instantly destroyed any
shred any shred of serious credibility I'd managed to salvage
with my admittedly naive but critical questions. Ken and George
hadn't contributed much to the conversation at this point, but
whenever they did, it would slightly bolster our social standing.
If there was one thing they were good at, especially Ken, it
was being the life of the party. He was a master of big grins,
inside jokes, and flattery. They had both the skills for a successful
business meeting. Sorry, they had both the skills for a successful
business meeting. The production talent and the marketing persuasiveness.
See here, I feel no sympathy. Well, I don't know. I feel some
sympathy. Anyway, we return to our hotel in Bucharest. Hold on
a second. Oh, never mind. We returned to our hotel in Bucharest,
feeling dejected, embarrassed, and unsure of where to go from
here. It wasn't our first failure, and we knew it wouldn't be
our last, but we needed to sleep and recharge before figuring
out the next step. Expecting to retreat to my room and binge
some prison break on my phone, Ken suddenly lit up with a completely
different energy. They want to meet with you, Lauren. To be perfectly
honest, I can't remember whether it was Ken or Tommy who got
the text. It was a confusing game of telephone between different
people. Maybe Tommy texted Ken or maybe it was the other way
around, but for some reason I wasn't the only one who got him
the invite directly. What? Yeah, they just reached out saying
you impressed them at the meeting and the deal is still on if
you're willing to meet them or sorry, meet with them before you
leave tomorrow and sort out the details. Now, if you're reading
this and screaming, "No, Lauren, I get it. I understand now.
But there's very little you could have told a 22-year-old me
to convince me I didn't have a real shot at saving the day."
Despite my imposter syndrome and self-doubt, flying the seat
by the seat of my pants had generally worked up to this point.
Maybe I could be the key to getting this entire media empire
off the ground. Imagine that. Me saving the day. It seemed like
a meeting free from the distraction of a cl drug uh sorry, a
drugged out motormouth might actually get somewhere. I clung
to the fantasy that I could turn this into something meaningful.
As if my ambition could somehow justify the risk. Uh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Unlucky. Unfortunate.
Uh, you skipped a paragraph. I skipped a whole paragraph. What?
Oh. However, considering we were all a decade younger than Tommy,
we were hardly the focus of business of the business discussions.
By the time we were leaving to get in the cars, Callen, George,
and I had resigned ourselves to the reality that the whole thing
was a bust. We did our best, but no one with even a fraction
of their wits would give us any access to real money, knowing
it would all end up being snorted up Tommy's nose.
Turn to our hotel feeling dejected. So, I I missed the part about
them missing or sorry, it up knowing they it up. So then Lauren
says, you know, that she's going to she thinks she can save the
day. All right. They sent a car for me and we headed back to
the compound where the same group of men were waiting were waiting.
No one was sitting at the desk. No papers or computers were out.
They were just wandering around conversing while I awkwardly
waited for some kind of prompt to continue our discussions. Hey
Lauren, get over here. Andrew waved me over to the couch. I want
a picture with you. Tape barked it more like an order, but his
singong tone kept it light, almost playful. By now, I was used
to it. Ever since my sudden rise to internet fame a few years
ago, people asked me for a photo. People asking me for photos
had become routine. I barely thought twice about it. I sat beside
him and he casually wrapped his hand around my waist and tugged
me in as someone snapped the shot. I wasn't used to men grabbing
me like that. Tate did it like we've been dating for years or
something. It left me slightly uncomfortable, but I brushed it
off. I still wonder what's become of that photo. It's probably
on an old phone somewhere. This is boring. Let's go somewhere
more exciting. Andrew snapped while pacing. Tristan and the others
agreed. Now, I was naive, but I wasn't that much of an idiot.
I asked again when we discussed business and where exactly we
wanted to go or they wanted to go to the club. It's just around
the block. We can take the cars. It'll be fun. We'll discuss
business there. At that moment, my nearly non-functional Amydala
kicked in for the first time in ages, sending off alarm bells.
Maybe Toby knew these people, but I didn't. Climbing into some
flashy sports car with strangers bound for a Euro trash club
I'd never even heard of. All while no one had a clue where I
was. Yeah, hard pass. I looked for a way to play it cool. Hey,
I'd rather not get out, go out, unless Tommy and the boys are
coming, too, I said, trying to keep it light. I've already texted
them. We're sending a car now, Andrew replied assuredly with
a twinkle in his eye. Well, my excuse was gone. I'm sure if I'd
really pushed, I could have demanded they take me back to my
hotel. They probably would have taken me, but I wasn't thinking
clearly. I was still on autopilot, lacking a strong sense of
self, easily swayed by the smallest bits of pressure. The most
dangerous thing a young woman can be is a pushover. Given my
own experiences, I can honestly say it's better to raise a [__]
than a people pleaser. I imagine the same goes for men in their
own way. We got in the cars and Andrew raced
uh Andrew raced through the back roads. Not long after, we pulled
up to the club, an all black brick building with a bouncer at
the door. The luxury cars were parked out front. The low boom
of bass music thudded underfoot as we walked down a narrow, dimly
lit hallway to the main
>> Feel so much anxiety as this story is being read. Yeah,
it's uh it's not great. It's not great. It's not great. Okay,
it's not great. Okay,
we are
Andrew. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Right here. I'm sure you've seen this
scene in movies. Everything slows down. The background blurs
and someone steps through a doorway into another or into another
world. I turned the corner and blue neon light flooded my vision.
Stages with gorgeous women, white leather couches. And was that
fireworks?
Hold on one second. Just need to make sure my still working.
Okay, it is. Okay. And was that fireworks? It was I didn't even
know what bottle service was at the time, but the whole vibe
of the place was mesmerizing. I paint I was painfully out of
place, an obvious North American, wearing jeans and a black top
surrounded by Romanian girls in club dresses. Andrew offered
to get me a drink. He snapped his fingers and waved over a serving
girl briskly ordering for both of us. Vodka soda, my usual, with
lime. I was handed my drink and just before taking a sip, I asked
any news on Tommy and the boys. Andrew turned to me, meeting
my eyes with intent. They'll be here soon, don't worry. He winked.
After spending time with him earlier in the in the day, I felt
a certain warmth toward him. There was something about his energy
that was calming, easy to lean into, easier to easier still to
ignore the small things that didn't sit quite right. People in
the club kept approaching Andrew and Tristan, shaking their hands,
and chatting like old friends. They were clearly regulars here.
I spent at least 10 minutes just trying to process my surroundings.
The music blasting, the unfamiliar faces, the unspoken social
cues I was clearly missing. The Tape brothers moved through it
all effortlessly. naturals in the world. Naturals in this world.
While they swam with ease, I felt like I was drowning. I figured
I'd try to talk to Donnie as he seemed to be the brains behind
their operation. The financials at least. Honestly, I still hadn't
quite figured out what the hell was going on. We exchanged some
small talk about Bitcoin before but before I could get a sense
of where the conversation was heading, a tray of shots was brought
over. The brothers ushered us all to take to cheers with them.
While I sipped on my vodka soda, I wasn't quite ready for another
drink until Tommy and the others arrived. Where's Tommy? Where
are Kellen and George? I shouted past the tray, my voice barely
carrying over the pounding music. The cars just arrived. They're
on their way now. Andrew reassured me, leaning in close with
his head still pressed near mine. His voice cut through the noise
with ease, steady and sure. She thinks they're so cool. A little
bit. How do we get on to night call anyway? Okay. I studied the
shot glass and despite my hesitation, seeing the rest raised
them, I joined in and we all threw them back. I winced as the
burn hit. I never really got used to drinking anything stronger
than vodk than my vodka sodas. It's funny how an environment
itself can make a behavior oddly natural. Surrounded by music,
fireworks, and the shimmering energy of the club, I would it
would feel weird to decline. Who's Tommy? Tommy Robinson. Yeah,
Tommy Robinson. Okay. Despite only having one shot and still
working on my vodka soda, I found myself suddenly feeling surprisingly
intoxicated.
Usually, only beer hit me this quick. I paid it no mind as I
was fast distracted with the conversation. So, I think there's
possibly like some questioning undertone here that she thinks
there might have been something more than just booze in one of
her drinks, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay, we all pick it up.
I'm just I'm not going to comment on it too heavily. We'll we'll
keep going. I paid it no mind as I fast distance with the uh
as I was fast distracted with conversation. Maybe it was the
vibe of the club or just the fact that I was coming off of as
a stereotypically fun, carefree blonde. But Donnie, who'd been
friendly enough as we bantered about politics and online culture,
suddenly seemed to take my relaxed demeanor as a green light.
Or perhaps it was one of the two edgy jokes I tossed out. Either
way, his tone shifted. It was far more candid now. Yelling over
the music, not yet drunk, he launched into an explanation of
their entire operation. A series of pump and dump crypto schemes
raking in millions. He didn't try to hide it. It was all basically
illegal and something they couldn't pull off in the US. We've
got the police wrapped around our fingers here, he bragged. Andrew
had said almost the same thing at the compound during our initial
meeting. But I brushed it off as some cheeky over-the-top bravado.
Donnie went on an inside guy. We can do whatever we want and
they can't do. He almost laughed as he said it. High on the absurdity.
And even if they do come after us, we'll just shut down shop,
take the money, and run to another Eastern European. Hell, I'm
getting close to that point now. We'll cash out and disappear.
Who's Donnie? I want to know who Donnie is. I want to know who
Donnie is. Can you throw a link in chat to the article you're
reading, please? Yes, I can. This is the article. This is Lauren
Southern's Substack post. Well, they're saying Donnie is in there
comparing him to Donnie from Wolf of Wall Street. That's who
they think. That's who they think it is, right? Sorry. That's
who she said. She said that the guy reminds her of Donnie from
Wolf of Wall Street. That's Jonah Hill's character in Wolf of
Wall Street. That's why she's calling him Donnie. She didn't
know his name. Anyway, at this moment, any hope that the night
might shift toward a legitimate investment discussion had faded
entirely. In fact, I was struggling just to keep my eyes open.
We hadn't even been there that long, and I hadn't drunk much.
But something was wrong. My body wasn't listening to me. The
world was dimming, and I couldn't stop it. I asked again about
Tommy and the others, but kept getting vague answers. Just around
the corner, they said. Eventually, I found myself crawling onto
a couch at the back of the club, my eyelids fluttering closed.
Blue lasers and neon lights danced behind them. Sorry, blue lasers
and neon lights dance behind them. Oh, behind her eyes, dragging
me in and out of consciousness, pulsing to the relentless hum
of the heavy bass. I thought I felt a girl shake my shoulder,
asking if I was okay. Honestly, I didn't care about anything
except keeping my head in a comfortable spot on the faux white
le white faux leather couch. Time lost all meeting. I couldn't
tell if 10 minutes or an hour had passed. Tommy and the boys
never showed up. As far as I know, a car was never even sent
for them. The memories after that blur together. I remember someone
carrying me to a bathroom, standing outside the stall while I
threw up. The nausea was overwhelming, and I think I might have
even fallen asleep, hugging the toilet for a while. Then Andrew
was there, lifting me up and carried me through the dim hallway,
my feet barely touching the ground. The bass of music still shaking
my body. I felt the cool night air hit my skin as the door to
a sports car opened in front of me. A stupid Bugatti, I'm sure.
Oh boy, got a lot of hate for these guys. Okay, chapter 11, confessions.
So, I'm wondering here if I should pause and take a moment to
look at some of the other stuff around this cuz we'll we'll take
a look. This is all I could see a whole bunch of people totally
discounting this, right? Oh, this was the post I saw about actual
Justice Warrior, right? So, somebody asked how how about we withhold
judgment until the evidence is presented. There isn't ever going
to be evidence presented. The goal is destruction, not justice.
I think she intentionally presented the evidence to a few media
outlets int like basically very intentionally to not let her
privacy be violated, but still try to give some semblance of,
hey, I've I've made this available to multiple people who could
disagree with me or or discount it, and they haven't. Would a
medical So somebody asked, would a medical report that existed
within a week of the incident count as valid evidence, or is
there nothing that would convince you that the Tates are just
horrible people that don't need to be defended? I'm Sean 90 claims
he saw the saw the reports along with some other evidence that
makes him believe it's likely true. Isn't that convenient? See,
this is uh I wanted to ask Andrew about this, and it does seem
like he's just going to go that way, right? Like basically any
evidence that could be provided here is never going to be enough.
You need a video. as the Romanian cops should be bringing the
hounds to them that backyard. I want justice. The justice this
is lying because of other probable assaulters said so. Well,
I think what is Andrew Wilson going on here? I think he's going
off of possibly some of the Rolo stuff. He'd be going off of
like how how she treated Rolo and lied to him. That would be
a big thing. I don't know what else he'd be going off of. Maybe
Tommy Robinson. I think she's had some bad things to say about
Tommy Robinson, obviously. How can anyone listen to anything
Tate says and not believe he hasn't multiple women? It's stupid
to be so blind at evaluating media figures. I tend to agree with
you on that. He certainly comes off as a scumbag. Way more likely
your vision would be spinning than uncontrollably falling asleep
from alcohol. Not being able to stay awake sounds like drugs.
Well, I think the amount of drinks, too. So, she had one shot
and one vodka soda, she says. And that she's like passing out
because of that, right? Anyway, I'm just thinking at some point
I'm going to get the the Shawn video in. Should I get it in now?
Did I not grab it? This got to be it, right? Well, hello there.
>> I'm not Lauren Southern and welcome to Fascist Times.
Today we are going to be finding out if the Australian public
>> So, Lauren Southern drops a bomb in new book 5 hours
ago. I believe this is around this is basically aligned. Let's
check the timestamps. This is 5 hours ago here and right here
we've got it uh 7 hours ago. So, within two hours of her video
dropping, Sean drops his own video. I assume this is coordinated
intentionally. He was one of the people who's provided with evidence
and she probably said, "Hey, could you could you like make a
video on this and just say your thoughts, I would assume, right?
He he'll probably address it in fact. So, let's check this out
before we get into the the rest of the book here." Uh, you know
what? Actually, I'm going to do one more chapter and then we'll
get into the video. Okay? We'll do one more chapter, then we'll
get into the video. Chapter 11, confessions.
It was kind of my fault. I can trace every moment I had the opportunity
to turn things around, right up until the point where everything
went wrong. The truth is, I could have said no to that strange
business meeting overseas, at least until I had more information.
I could have refused to go to the club until my friends were
with me. I could have turned down the drinks with whatever little
sense I had left. I could have said no to what I foolishly thought
was a harmless cuddle when I had no intention of going any further.
But honestly, I'm not sure it would have mattered at that point.
This wasn't a case of mixed signals or intoxicated blurred lines.
I thought back. I was pleading. I just didn't realize there was
a point of no return. A moment where my voice would no longer
have any power. I'd rather not give a detailed account. So, I'll
keep it simple. He carried me back to the hotel room and asked
me to sleep beside him. I said yes. I was incredibly intoxicated
and some part of me convinced myself that because he was Tommy's
friend, he wasn't particularly dangerous. It was a poor decision,
but it happened. He kissed me. I wasn't expecting it. I wasn't
looking for it, but I kissed him back briefly and then told him
I wanted to sleep. I was extraordinarily tired. He wanted to
go further. I said no very clearly multiple times and tried to
pull his hands off of me. He put his arm around my neck and began
strangling me unconscious. I tried to fight back. He repeatedly
strangled me every time I regained enough consciousness to pull
at his arms. I'd prefer not to share the rest. It's pretty obvious.
Oh, that's brutal. Yeah, it's pretty bad. So, I think that's
it's pretty obvious, right? Like, it's pretty obvious what it's
not like uh it's not like, oh, we mixed we mixed up or whatever.
It's um it's it's not like that. So, I've mentioned it before,
but I'm once again reminded of how deeply I used to believe in
that naive, almost cartoonish version of life where I was the
main character. Nothing truly bad could happen, and danger didn't
exist as long as you played it smart. H I held on to a teenage
radical anti-feminist idea that men weren't real, a real threat
unless you let them be one. I'd had experiences before where
I set boundaries and they were respected. Our night ended with
a cuddle, maybe a kiss, and that was it. No pressure, no problem.
Once or twice, I'd even crashed in a male friend's hotel room
or at their house after drinking without the slightest concern
they tried anything. The next morning, it was just good morning.
Hope you're feeling better. Ah,
I'm not saying these were good decisions, and I'm incredibly
militant now that about never putting myself in a position like
that again, but that was my lived experience. I believed I could
take all the risks I wanted and still be fine. I didn't know
how to cope when that belief shattered. When I finally faced
the real consequences of taking those risks, it broke me psychologically.
I cycled through different forms of denial. It's taken me years
to even begin to process it clearly and to take full responsibility
for my own behavior.
Give me a second.
>> Just give me a second. Give me a second.
>> Okay. Uh, it's easier to convince ourselves that evil
completely ens snares us without our willingness on our part,
without any willingness on our part. But evil isn't always obvious
stuff. It's the small decisions we make that put us in compromising
positions. I heard this anecdote once that the devil doesn't
just leap at anyone or leap out at anyone. He whispers, urging
us to step a little closer to the fence, to come see what he's
doing, to lower our defenses, have a drink, and not think too
much. We indulge. We take a step forward. and he tells us small
lies how all our friends will soon be at the fence curious too.
>> He reassures us that it's safe to sit on the fence between
him and God to get a re better view of what he's offering without
making any real decisions. But then in the final moment, you
feel claws around your arm dragging you screaming while the devil
smiles and tells you the fence always belonged to him. You can
scream all you want about how you never wanted to go along. You
can fight back in vain, but deep down a part of you allowed yourself
to get wrapped up in the lies. You drank wine. You drank the
wine he offers. You let yourself get that close. You don't have
discernment. Don't get vulnerable with the devil if you don't
want to end up in hell. I mean, really,
>> he talks background music. I don't even know what would
be appropriate background music for this, to be honest. So, I
feel like anything's going to be like kind of a thing, so I'm
just letting my normal background music play. I suppose I can't
entirely fault conservative media for turning Andrew Tate into
a hero. Though, for a while, I certainly did.
He's not a fool. Despite the persona he graphs online, there's
a depth to him, a sharp social intelligence that in another life
might have been a force for good. It's a true shame. You can
catch glimpses of that potential in his messages urging men to
better themselves. But in the end, even those moments are not
separate from the larger arc of his influence. They too are absorbed
into a worldview where power is the only currency and dominance,
not character, defines a man's worth. My frustration grew over
time, though, as more and more evidence came to light about this
man's operations. At least when I met him, I had no idea. My
comfortable state of denial was being involuntarily shattered.
Involuntarily shattered daily. Videos and messages surfaced of
Tate discussing grooming underage girls, manipulating and lying
to put women in horrific situations, and scamming men out of
their entire life savings. As I write this, he's still under
house arrest for alleged sex trafficking and exploitation, including
repeated relations and acts with a 15-year-old. Frankly, you
didn't need my story to see desri to see the direction it all
pointed. You could just listen to what the man himself was saying.
I understand the concept of radical responsibility. Well, women
have freedom now. They can make choices and put themselves put
them in that put them in danger or compromise them. Oh well,
you asked for this, ladies. Fine. So be it. Blame the women.
What I don't understand is how the right-wing media in particular
could make a hero of this man after all the evidence his character
has been released. Conservatives, even just a hundred years ago,
would have strung up people in the streets for less than what
tape the tape brothers do on any given weekend. Men then understood
that part of building a strong society is protecting people,
especially young women, from predators and pimps. Instead, we
got a bunch of self-proclaimed conservative men who had dragged
themselves naked across broken glass for the chance to serve
soft up soft uh up softball interviews with a man who is facing
nearly three times as many charges as Hunter Biden ever did.
Each of them far more serious. Can you imagine if a Democrat
had said even a fraction of what was stated in his Hustler University
videos? We've got a library of damning tape footage. Epste never
even gave us that much to work with. Tate literally admitted
to moving to Romania because it's easier to get away with crimes.
Not sure if it was known who he was in 2018. It wasn't. She's
she's basically condemning
that even though as he was rising as an influencer, people still
kind of sucked this guy's even though he put all this content
out there. There's every reason to believe he's a horrible person.
Um I believe during his rise or s shortly um before his major
rise the ken guy literally said Andrew Tate's a friend of mine
in 2018 like right her video editor her friend said Andrew Tate
a friend of mine in 2018 um so there's like a lot of stuff out
there for people who really cared to look people who had you
know who would have had their reputations destroyed if this guy
came out as like a major predator and I think they they broadly
weren't really looking she's not blaming herself here she's talking
I believe she's talking about after Andrew blew up after he published
Hustlers University. He talked about how he scammed women out
of their their share of money by faking their tax forms and right
after all of this. I think she's saying he did all of this and
people still worshiped him. So, I have spite for these people,
right? I have a lot of spite for the people who worship this
guy despite him basically platforming exactly who he was, which
seems pretty
>> I don't feel one bit bad for her. She spent years fear-mongering
about immigrants, white women, only to get raped by a British
American guy. No sympathy. To be fair, he is a half black British
American guy. So, some of her ideology. Okay. Uh, that's the
only joke we're going to do that. I didn't even I even pulled
back on that one. Okay. I even pulled back on that one. It's
not like she's totally wrong in being racist. Okay. Okay. Kenny,
don't take that personally. That's just me. She's obviously wrong
in being racist. Andrew Tate is a piece of That's outside of
his genetics. Okay. that's totally outside of his genetics that
he is a complete piece of We don't have to know his genetics.
We could just look at what he said personally, what he has said
about himself and the things he's done and we can identify him
as a piece of just from text. We wouldn't have to know what he
looks like or who he is.
>> I don't feel bad for her now that she's championed this
group for eight years after the fact. >> Where did she
champion any of them? Hold on. What is that? Well, thank you
for the gifted sub. Uh guys, I should take this opportunity to
chill. We are six subs away from another hour on the stream.
If you like the content, you can follow us here. You can follow
us on Twitch, twitch.tv/jdlk
with an underscore or x.com/jdlk with an underscore. The other
two places we're broadcasting. Follow the Twitter page. We're
looking forward. We're looking to rebuild the Twitter. We'll
have to start posting a lot more. I think maybe about stuff like
this. I think uh my frustration with with this story and how
it's being handled so far mostly comes from people not really
reading this stuff before commenting on it, right? Like before
I want to go make a like a full statement on how I feel about
this on Twitter. I would like to read it first, right? I don't
want to I don't want to go, "Oh, Lauren Southern is totally right
or Lauren Southern's totally wrong. Lauren Southern's a lying
or Lauren Southern could do nothing wrong." I don't want to post
either of those opinions, right? I don't know why people jumped
out of the gate like there's no way Andrew Tate like one that's
a base level even if it wasn't somebody popular saying it, okay?
Or somebody with a following saying it. The fact that this person
has a following probably and an online reputation should probably
lend some credence to the claim. Not a lot, but some. Certainly,
she has more to risk. Although, again, maybe you get a little
annoyed that she hasn't taken enough risk here.
She's gained no charity to research any claims she makes. People
just give her the same effort she made in the last 10 years.
O, Lowi, that's uh that's pretty up. I just listen um this person
clearly feels like their previous life was a mistake in many
many ways. And I don't know. I I just don't I think people can
change. Like people can broadly change. How long does this person
have to more or less sit off the internet, right? I know she
did the tenant media stuff, but she took a long break from the
internet and she took another long break from the internet. How
long does she she have to sit off the internet before you believe
that she really regrets like her previous job or whatever book
makes sense after that video in the woods? Yeah, it's pretty
much the next thing. Her bank account changed. I'm not denying
that. But I would say that's the pro probably the best criticism
is that she wasn't going to out these people or get on the bad
side of a lot of other conservative influencers online or risk
that while she still had a job in that field. Now ultimately
you have to decide for yourself like where your morals lie on
that. I personally understand how somebody could compromise or
how it's not clear. A lot of people who when they're in this
situation, they won't see that line clearly. I am compromising
my morals to protect this guy because I need my job. They won't
see it that way. They will rationalize it in small ways to themselves
over time. And you can absolutely hate them for that, okay? But
you should understand that it's not them going, I know that I'm
protecting a to keep my job. I do not believe Lawrence Southern
really like truly felt that directly. If she felt that directly,
If she felt that directly, I do not believe I do not believe
that she would have kept doing it. I think they were like, "Well,
you know, I can't really do more than I've done." Well, like
I've, you know, I tried talking to the British police. They wouldn't
do anything. The Romanian police, like she probably rationalized
how she couldn't do anything about it and how she was going to
let it go. And how actually, you know, uh I believe and I've
said before that actually it's really bad for women to make allegations
without solid proof. How does she rationalize that, right? She
doesn't have any solid proof after the fact. She's just got her
word against his, right? How does she rationalize making a allegation
against somebody who people don't even know,
>> right? It's like it would be very difficult to actually
go out and do those things. So, I don't have a ton of judgment
for somebody who fails to do those things. Now,
>> how how should I put it? Not a ton of judgment. I have
some judgment, but it's it's tempered by I should say I have
judgment, but it's tempered by the reality of the situation.
How I know that this is difficult. I know it's something very
difficult for most people to do. And so, I kind of I measure
her against how I feel most people would
>> Plus the self-lame. Yeah. I'm sure like she was raised
in a conservative Christian household with conservative Christian
values. There's probably like a lot of this was like, "Yeah,
I probably like she might have even thought after the fact like,
oh yeah, I you know, I this up. That's that's my bad. I made
stupid decisions and I'm to blame for it.
>> You're not seeing my POV. She's a Okay. Okay, dude.
>> You know her personally? I'm not saying I know her personally.
Oh, I'm talking about what she's talked about and I'm basically
taking the fact that she's like a right-wing social media influencer
from like a very young age
>> I mean it's possible she wasn't raised Christian but
I that feels like that would get exposed pretty easily if she
was lying about it.
>> Oh, you're talking to a chatter. All right. All right.
All right.
>> Okay.
My Okay. My frustration grew over time. We might have read this
>> as more my frustration grew over time about Andrew Tape
being turned into a hero by conservative media. Though as more
and more evidence came to light about this man's operations,
at least when I met him, I had no idea. My comfortable state
of denial was being involuntarily shattered daily. Videos and
messages surfaced of tape discussing grooming underage girls,
manipulating and lying to put women in horrific situ. We read
this actually. Uh, okay. What I don't understand is how right-wing
media in particular could make a hero of this man after all the
character evidence. This is the Hunter Biden thing. We read that.
Sorry, I was scrolling up and down a lot. My bad. I lost her
place. When it comes to conservative media's reaction, it was
willful ignorance in pursuit of fame and money. Nothing short
of that. A lot of So, I wonder if she will actually put that
on herself at all. Um, for not coming up with this over the years.
When it comes to conservative media's reaction, it was willful
ignorance in pursuit of fame and money. Nothing short of that.
A lot of people received a lot of money and attention to pick
aside and cover up what they certainly knew to be morally rotten
behavior, if not significantly crim significant criminality.
Oh, don't forget the fear. A lot of influencers had been to that
compound. A lot of people with high public profile profiles had
been involved in that business. I didn't even realize how bad
things were, how deep the rot went in the media space at this
point. No matter I no matter I had the intentions of getting
into it. How embarrassing was it I even ended up in that situation
in the first place? Who was I to blame conservative media figures
for lionizing Tate when I had my own failures as a self-proclaimed
conservative media figure under my belt? Not to mention, I'm
sure I conducted a few softball interviews of my own. In my first
draft of this section, I just brushed over this entire experience.
Of course, the same thing I did all those years ago. It didn't
happen, I told myself. In fact, Andrew and I were on great terms.
We were still talking over WhatsApp. He was asking me to visit
or he was asking to visit me. I had no intention of allowing
that to occur, but I humored him to preserve my sanity, my own
sanity, or maybe my or maybe further my own delusion.
>> It's a question. Or maybe further my own delusion.
I wasn't sure. In the end, I thought it didn't matter. All I
knew was I wasn't going to let myself care about it so deeply,
so I acted like I didn't. Cognitive dissonance makes people normalize
the absurd, as if mentally reclassifying the event afterward
can restore some of the some illusion of control. The last conversation
we had in person consisted of Andrew telling me I'd better not
tell the press about what he'd done as I packed my bags to rush
out of the hotel room. I told him not to worry. I was a girl
again. I was the girl against feminism after all. I couldn't
be doing that. I'd spent so long fighting the idea of victimhood
on ideological grounds that of course I would ignore my own on
those same grounds. It wouldn't be very helpful to the cause
or my career for that matter for me to become exactly what I
criticized. Oh, she actually did confront this directly. That's
not great. Um, it sucks. It sucks that she became this, but it
probably sucks worse. And I'm not going to listen. She is out
here confessing to this, right? She is out here saying, "I up.
This was up.
It's difficult for me to go that hard on her." But she is straight
up saying that like, "Hey, I'm the girl against feminism. I totally
my career if I did this." And I'm not willing to do that right
now. So,
>> you know, it is what it is. We continue.
wouldn't be very helpful to the cause or my career for that matter
for me to become exactly what I criticized, a victim. Worse,
a woman, a victim of a man, who one who literally did everything
wrong. Why was I out drinking in this strange country with strange
men? What did I expect? I didn't allow myself to consider that
there would be others after me. If I did, I figured they made
a stupid stupid I figured they made stupid decisions the same
as I did. I certainly never imagined the minds of an entire generation
would be assaulted by Tate, not just dozens of women. I can't
help but wonder if there was a moment where I when I could have
been more honest, more direct about the forces that would later
shape the psyche of millions. Maybe it wouldn't have changed
anything. And maybe it would have made a difference to someone,
given a few people a a reason to pause to think twice. Instead,
I told him his secret was safe with me. What was one more secret
in the world, this world of politics anyway?
Took a few weeks before my denial was slowly replaced by a small
but persistent sense of guilt. Guilt that I was setting up setting
others up for failure. Even if I could take responsibility for
my own mistakes, I knew that his actions weren't mistakes. They
were calculated and intentional. I finally cracked and texted
him, breaking the act, stating what he did was wrong, and at
the very least, he needed to understand that so he wouldn't treat
others the same way. Of course, I knew he already I knew he already
knew this. But I also was certain I would never go to court.
I didn't believe in punishing anyone over such a serious accusation
without overwhelming evidence. That's
h I can just see it, right? This is she's basically the exact
reason Andrew Wilson is calling her a lying before reading anything
is because this is like the general belief right now. The fact
of the matter is in basically every case of rape you don't have
overwhelming evidence after the fact. Like there is not overwhelming.
You could you could go with like a with actual significant like
damage to yourself and get a kit and get the the sample and stuff
and you could still not have like an overwhelming case or something,
right? You could be drugged, you could be a whole bunch of stuff,
right? So, that's the problem is you're just never going to have
overwhelming evidence in this case. And while it is difficult
to, you know, judge somebody or or come to like a firm conclusion
on them, it's like we have to we have to figure out a different
dynamic than just the like never make a serious accusation without
overwhelming
>> It's only proof happened. Well, there could be like
tissue damage or, you know, in this case maybe some amount of
like uh airway damage. Who knows? Anyway, I didn't believe in
punishing any Oh, sorry. Uh, I wouldn't have believed another
woman who made these exact set of claims. In fact, I would have
torn myself apart. I wouldn't have been able to survive my own
scrutiny. I made too many decisions that indicated at the very
least reckless
As for holding to a public account publicly, good joke. I already
knew how that would go. Whether a crime had been committed, uh,
whether a crime had been committed would be a secondary concern.
The real question would be whether I was the kind of person who
deserved whether I was the kind of person who deserved my fate.
Every failed relationship, every poor decision, every moment
of bad judgment would be dissected under a microscope. For Tate,
hiring a PR firm and weaponizing other influencers, especially
those whose reputations are tied to yours, to discredit potential
claimants, is just the cost of doing business. Best case, my
story gets hijacked by some slick HBO showrunner with a savior
complex repackaged into glossy docky drama where the woman where
the women are written as if they've got no internal monologue.
Idiots, victims of hyper captivating men. The outcome was painfully
well unfortunately.
It's not really important, but like I think she should that is
what happened to her, right? She did not have the internal monologue,
the thoughts to like get out of there in a lot of ways. And I'm
not blaming her for that. She was young. She was like going you
like it's up because you're you're literally somebody who's been
in that situation once or twice in your life and you're going
uh you have somebody who's chasing you who has done it like hundreds
of times, right? It's not a fair match in a lot of ways. Women
shouldn't be sleeping in the same bed as a man in a hotel room
if they don't want to have sex. It's unfortunately just common
sense. Uh Beavertale, how did she get into that bed?
>> Do you remember?
Beavertale, do you remember how she got into that bed? She walked
in. No, she was drunk. She basically was passing out, puking
her guts out, and Andrew Tate carried her back to the room.
>> Or I mean, she might have been she might have been up
and walking, but she was carried she was carried back to the
hotel at some point, right? Or she was carried back to some room
at some point that's described here, right?
She said she said yes, she was going to cuddle. She said she
said yes to cuddling. Yes. Yep. I understand how this going to
catch people just like um who's the girl with the tattoo that
cut. come on it just like that girl, right? But that doesn't
that doesn't make it okay. We still believe that consent like
applies throughout the entire interaction. We do believe it.
Well, she would say take accountability if there's another woman
in the same story with the same story. No, you know what? You
know how I know that? It's because she literally said the exact
same thing. No, I didn't. I wouldn't have believed another woman
who made these exact set of claims. In fact, I would have tore
myself apart. I wouldn't have been able to survive my own scrutiny.
I made too many decisions that indicated at the very least reckless
irresponsibility. Yeah. No.
>> I really don't like the people who are like, "Yeah,
well, she shouldn't have had that flare out trying to get those
migrants around or something. She deserves to be raped." Okay.
She deserves to be She's tried to stop migrants from entering
Europe. This dumb I need to not hear that. Okay. I don't like
that. I'm not a fan.
Okay. The outcome was painfully obvious, especially with the
amount of money and blackmail play. People get killed over this
sort of stuff and I'd been privy to conversations with powerful
people that implied as much. My brief confrontation was less
about justice and more about easing my own guilt. The guilt of
knowing I was embarrassed by my own behavior in the situation
and that given the choice, I would absolutely stay silent for
the sake of the cause. Perhaps even more so to preserve my own
sense of guilt to avoid the reputational blood bath I feared.
I guess this is the real world, I told myself, and I'd be damned
before I admitted I hadn't been prepared for it. Andrew eventually
apologized for making me think badly of him, as he put it. But
the apology only came after a barrage of anger and veiled threats.
He reminded me that I had consented to cuddling, that he'd been
drunk, too, as if those facts nullified everything that came
after. I told him plainly that I had said no, clearly and repeatedly,
and that he had gotten violent in response. He told me to go
to the police. I laughed and reminded him of his own words, that
the police were already paid off. I wasn't reaching out to seek
justice or vengeance. I just wanted him to understand I wouldn't
be complicit in his delusion that what he'd done was okay.
I thanked him for the apology and cut off contact.
He wrote reached out again and offered to bring flowers. I still
didn't reply. I know this is going to sound weird, but I do think
he meant his apology or at least I hoped it would enti he hoped
or sorry, he meant his apology or at least hoped it would entice
me to begin speaking with him again. Either way, I wasn't the
closure I it wasn't the closure I'd hoped for. I didn't expect
any though. It's now seven years later. I don't hate Andrew.
I know that may sound strange, especially in contrast to the
things I've expressed on these pages, but it's complex. He's
still human. When he apologized to me, he admitted he doesn't
have much of a conscience. But if it's still there, I hope he
wrestles with it. I hope he wrestles with it. I hope one day
it wins. I hope he becomes the soul he could have been instead
of the one that consumed uh one consumed by his vices, whether
behind bars or freed. But I don't think he even realizes he's
being consumed. Like so many in his position, he's likely never
let himself dig that deep because there's too much pain waiting
there. I believe change is possible. I absolutely believe in
redemption for Andrew Tate. But understanding why people do what
they do and hoping for their for their greatest spiritual good
doesn't mean they shouldn't be stopped, especially when they've
lost themselves so completely that they leave destruction in
their wake. I forgiven him truly, but that doesn't mean he should
be free to keep hurting, tormenting, and scamming others. If
I ever lost myself to that degree, sorry, if I ever lost myself
to that degree, there have been moments where those paths felt
dangerously close. I'd sorry, if I'd ever lost If I ever lost
myself to that degree, and there had been moments where those
paths felt dangerously close, I'd hope there would be people
willing to stand up to me. Additional note, upon completion of
this manuscript, I finally decided to leave in this section of
the book. At first, I wrote it just to process my own emotions,
convincing myself no one would ever read it. For a while, I thought
about replacing parts with dramatized anonymized scenes to avoid
drawing too much attention to it. But after a lot of reflection,
I've realized I've done with uh I'm done with cowardice. If I'm
going to do an honest book, I'll do it right. And this is a big
part of my story. Why now, though? It's a very valid question.
I know how people think. Oh, you're deciding to tell the story
in your book to make sales. What about the legal cases? Can't
believe you didn't help earlier. I should start by debunking
some misconceptions here. First, I will be releasing all the
chapters relevant to the to tape for free. It's not about money,
and frankly, I'd rather not give people an excuse to project
their own twisted motivations onto me. Not that I'm too worried
about the opinions of anyone who thinks human trafficking and
scamming men out of their life savings is some kind of noble
vocation.
Second, I've always believed these matters should be handled
by the legal system whenever possible rather than turned into
a public spectacle. As I mentioned earlier, I still I had no
desire to put my face on any public claims at first. Instead,
I oscillated between denial and my own harsh judgments of women
who came forward with similar accusations. Why didn't you go
to the police? That would be the right thing to do. Why didn't
you go to the hospital? That would be the right thing to do.
Ironically, my extreme judgment of others pushed me to make some
of the right choices early on. I embraced denial, but deep down
I knew what really happened. I reluctantly reached out to UK
the UK authorities the next day, feeling it was the right thing
to do, only to be met with indifference. They told me an investigation
could only be pursued in Romania, a country where I'd been explicitly
warned about police corruption. I went deeper into a dissoci
disassoci
disassociative
state.
Sorry. I went deeper into a disassociative state. As a result,
feeling certain there would never be a resolution.
Attempts to involve Canadian
authorities later led to similar dead ends. While I'm sure plenty
would like to claim an the investigation into Tate is a deep
state operation, if anything, the state didn't help at all. They
honestly didn't seem to give a [__] I wasn't looking
to start a legal battle. I was just looking for any interest
at all in helping me make sense of what was going on in Tate's
compound in a way that would make me that would keep me anonymous.
Years passed before Tate's antics made it into the onto the radar
of the Western authorities due to repeated claims from other
women that had nothing to do with me. Eventually, a larger US
investigation reached out for my assistance, and I provided what
information I could off the record. I did everything possible
while trying to maintain my anonymity. For the most part, I buried
it until I began writing this. Being a witness in any official
capacity would have required revealing my identity, something
I wanted to avoid at all costs. Still, over the years, public
exposure started to feel inevitable. Someone I once naively trusted
shared parts of my story with journalists without my consent.
That disclosure resulted in others posting distorted versions
of the events online or in published works for political act
for political activism purposes. Clearly with no real concern
about the potential crimes happening or whether I wanted my story
public or not. At one point, even Tommy, worried about his own
connection to a situation, put out a video trying to get ahead
of the stories circulating online by preemptively claiming I
would make false accusations. He recently did this again just
before the publication of this book, completely lying about the
events that occurred. You'll read more about that later. Ironically,
I was the last person. Ironically, I was the last person on earth
who wanted to talk about it. But everyone else, including those
who wanted me to remain silent, kept forcing the situation into
the spotlight. The more they did, the more journalists showed
up in my inbox prying for a statement I never wanted to give.
If my silence over the past 7 years hasn't made it clear enough,
the last thing I want uh wanted is attention for all this. I
have an entire archive of replies to those reporters telling
them to go off and leave me alone. Regardless, it's always felt
like a matter of like only a matter of time whether I chose to
tell the story myself or leave it to journalists, activists,
and paid smear campaigns to do it for me. I'd much rather tell
my own story with all its flaws than let a wave of outsiders
who have no real understanding of what actually happened shape
the narrative in my place. Of course, there will still be plenty
of commentary from old colleagues eager to highlight my character
flaws, some true, some not, to muddy the waters. It will be interesting,
though, to watch them contend with a simple fact. I've only made
two accusations of assault to authorities in my entire life.
One was in Australia where the handsy man was promptly arrested
and jailed after CCTV and his serial offense record confirmed
my account. The other being Andrew Tate who despite my silence
years later became infamous for allegations of human trafficking
and sexual assault.
Equally hard to pass off are as mere consider mere coincidence
is the fact that I went to a women's hospital and had a report
made around a week after the event. The report documented my
account of his es asphyxiation 5 years before Vice News would
report in 2023 that Tate used the same method on other victims
in the UK in 2015.
And there was some elaborate ploy for attention. Oh, so that's
an important fact is she says he choked me and he choked me to
the point I passed out and that there are other victims of Tate,
other people around Tate who have and he himself has said that
he likes to do this, right? So there are other people around
this who have who have done this. This is this is evidence that
predates public accounts. So, it seems far more likely to be
valid, right? When it's evidence that predates public accounts.
If there was some elaborate ploy for attention, I'd have to be
a clairvoyant to have predicted the rise of this man's profile
and his methods before anyone knew who he was. Not that anyone
wants this kind of attention. No one wants to be a victim, especially
not when you come for my political background. I know exactly
what's coming. I'll be crucified online. I'm not looking for
sympathy, and I don't expect a victim trophy from any side. I'll
be publishing this simply because it's the truth, and far too
few people are telling the truth these days. And here's another
sad truth about the political world. It's absolutely not just
women falling victim to violence. Young men are prayed on too,
often in the same spaces, often with the same devastating silence.
The social stigma and shame that keeps women quiet also keeps
men from speaking out, sometimes even more intensely. It reminds
me of the case of serial Rainard Saga in the UK who assaulted
at least 136 men. He was so difficult to catch because most of
his victims remained silent. Even when police presented them
with recorded evidence of their assaults, many still denied it
had happened. I understand. I really do. The culture needs to
change for both men and women. And that change shouldn't be politically
part a politically partisan issue. I don't have all the answers,
but I do know it won't happen by reducing the conversation to
slogans like believe all X or by reflexively dismissing people
as liars seeking attention. Personally, I prefer handling matters
privately and through legal channels. But as I hope you understand,
perhaps even more so after reading the this book in its entirety.
That was tr never truly an option for me. It isn't for everyone.
Sometimes the only solace people find is in telling their story.
Okay. All right. This is going to be about how she tells people
after the fact. I'm going to flip over to our actual justice
warrior video. So actual justice warrior is somebody who's given
evidence, right? Somebody who's given like uh contemporaneous
and supporting evidence for this allegation. and he's going to
confirm some of that and probably cover maybe some of the exactly
what the allegations are, maybe fill in some stuff. I actually
don't really know, but I do know his video is going to be valuable.
It's going to be interesting. It's going to be an addition to
what we've seen so far. Sounds like being willfully anti-feminist
really worked out for her. I mean, yeah, to be fair, she does
undercut that by just saying like, "Yeah, um, obviously I see
the irony here. Yeah, it's up. It's totally up." >> Well,
hello there. I'm not Lauren Southern and welcome to Factist
>> Okay. Also, I have to go to the bathroom really badly
and get water. So, >> today we are going to be finding
out if the Australian public would like to execute known fascist
Lauren Southern. >> After a long hiatus, Lauren Southern
is officially back.
Maybe not really. Well, she's released a book. And if I actually
time the release of this YouTube video appropriately, it should
go up on July 15th, 2025, the same day that her book drops. And
of course, it's a 50/50 chance I will completely mess up the
timing on that. But regardless, she has released a book entitled
This Is Not Real Life. It ends up chronicling her journey from
before she was internet famous to an overnight internet sensation.
And of course, it goes through the various steps along the way,
including when she had to pull away from conservative media,
her return, her suspicions about tenant media while she was working
there, and all these different various things that happened to
her over the course of her lengthy career. Now, full disclosure,
I actually found out about the existence of this book months
prior to any kind of notification to people out there that it
was going to be released. And this is because in one of the chapters,
I was actually featured in the book. And because of that, Lauren
reached out to me, sent me those pages in order to make sure
that she did the appropriate readactions in order to maintain
my privacy. And to be clear, when I got those chapters, I was
initially very disappointed. First of all, it was chapter 23.
And I had assumed just based on who I am that obviously the dedication
page would be to me. Obviously, she would write that I would
be her inspiration for her entire career. But in reality, that
didn't really make all that much sense, considering she started
her YouTube channel years before I ever had this YouTube channel.
And of course, maybe, just maybe, you guys might get the assumption
from reading the chapter that I'm actually included in that it's
more about the fact that Donald Trump was shot on the campaign
trail the same day that I ended up getting married. And therefore,
it is a superficial connection to say the least. But I'm just
going to tell you, and maybe it's not in the book, maybe I'm
making this up for comedic purposes. If you read between the
lines, you will clearly see that I am probably, if not definitely
the smartest, most important figure in the entire story. Again,
just kidding, guys. Just having some jokes. Now, of course, there
are some serious things in this particular book. There's a particular
set of allegations that I cannot go this whole video without
>> You guys think my delivery sucks. You guys think I'm
not funny. Holy [__] I just had to listen to that
while I went to the bathroom, got a drink. Holy Holy
Holy, this is rough. This is Sher says he held he's funny like
you. Shut up. He is not funny at all. That was Dude, he also
doesn't let his jokes hang at all. He doesn't like he just goes
on. He knows his jokes are bad. It's an edited video and he knows
his joke is bad and he doesn't let it hang or like hit at all.
He literally gives his joke no space in a video that's edited.
So, we're going to break this down. >> Make us laugh. Tell
Make us laugh. Tell us a joke. Show us how it's done. No thank
you. >> We're going to talk about this. But >> my
my jokes are observational humor in the moment, okay? They come
to me. They're inspiration. They strike me like inspiration.
I've never tried to force it like this. Okay, this is gross.
>> Before we do, I want to thank everybody who supports
this channel via
>> like how he lets you know it's a joke. So there's no
confusion. Also,
okay, it doesn't matter. It actually doesn't matter, but it's
just a little interesting that he's he like makes total light
of like the book and all this stuff. And then also shills and
then Oh, he does the give me the money. Yeah, he does the he
does the Anna Kasparian thing. Where is it? Here. Do I got it?
>> Give me the money. >> Give Give me the money.
>> Give me the money. Give you give me the money. Okay.
Should we Lauren Southern? >> She's the like the blonde
like
>> Yeah, she's the that's coming here with a far right
event. >> I'm not sure if we should kill her, but I don't
think we should be listening to what she's >> What
uh guys, also if you're on Twitch, we're going to head over to
kick only for the rest of the stream. So, I love you guys. I
love you Twitch viewers. I'm going to put the kick link in the
comments here or in the Twitch chat here. You guys can head over
to kick. We're doing kick only for the rest of the stream. Good
luck. Have fun.
covering Ms. Lauren Southern and her allegations right now. Okay,
we're on to the actual Justice Warrior stuff. Okay. All right.
We'll talk to you guys later. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. See you, Twitch.
See you, Twitch. There it is, guys. Also, we are, I believe,
five subs away from two more hours on the stream. So, you know,
that's a shill. That's a shill. Sub on kick gift uh gift subs,
sub on Twitch, Twitch Prime, Twitch subs, whatever you want to
do. Every dollar goes towards more time on the stream. Thank
you very much for being here. Let's continue on with the AJW
video. >> Like the blonde like political. >> Yeah,
she's the that's coming here with a far right event. I'm not
sure if we should her, but I don't think we should be listening
to what she's saying. >> So, right off the top, >> it's
so cringe that Lauren Southern's going around and saying, should
we Lauren Southern? >> Just a little odd. >> I just
want to make something 100% clear. I'm going to give this book
a strong recommend. I have not made it all the way through the
entirety of the book, but there's certain >> uh anonymous.
Thank you very much for the five gifted. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> That's awesome. That gets us to two
>> Perfect. And it's just the perfect amount of time. 3
44 26.
>> It's the perfect amount of time so that we can actually
just reset the submeter and we're all of our all of our meters
are lined up. No editing required. Perfect. Thank you guys. certain
chapters that I find to be incredibly interesting, like when
the whole tenant media situation was popping off in the chapter
called Jason, where Lauren is essentially being interrogated
and intimidated by an agent, and we get really close and intimate
looks at her mindset in this particular situation. Even it wasn't
a random knock at the door, I was more prepared for the chat.
We shook hands, exchanged a plate hello, and I excused myself
to the washroom. From in front of the mirror, I stared at my
reflection, solid hard, took a deep breath, and pulled the recording
device from my pocket. A tiny DJI mic, clipped it near to the
center of my bra, and hit record. The soft beep confirmed it
was live. Leaning forward, I shifted to the side, checking to
make sure it wasn't visible. Was she wearing a wire? Oh my god.
Including her strapping a DJI mic to her underneath her clothing
in order to record what is going on in these conversations because
she's absolutely terrified of being entrapped by the Fed. So,
we get a good look at this whole investigation. We get to see
the dirty tactics of the government. We get to hear about them
basically threatening her access to her own child in response
to her refusal to cooperate. And honestly, she could have just
played the role of the tough girl. I'm going to fight back against
everything. But in reality, she admits throughout the course
of this particular chapter that she was actually intimidated
enough to the point that she was seriously considering cooperating
with this federal agent. So, it gives you a real look at the
dirty tactics of the feds. You also get a look at the dark underbelly
of conservative media. >> The Canadian feds. I thought
she talked about the Canadian feds and how they treated her in
her hearing if I'm not mistaken. I believe she talked about them
in her hearing, but I'm not 100% sure. I don't know. And I think
I've described Lauren like this in the past, but she gives like
kind of the vibe that you would get from a typical noir character
where they come from a small town. In this case, it's Canadia
Land. They threatened to take her kid kids away, I or her kid
away, I believe. So I think she alleged that when she was testifying
in front of the Canadian >> They end up in the big city.
In this case, it's conservative media. And essentially, they
get swallowed up by the big city. Now, of course, in those noir
films, often times the girl at the center of this ends up getting
killed and then the mystery is to solve her murder or something
of the sort. In this particular case, Lauren's spirit seems to
be the thing that was crushed, but of course, she ended up making
it through the other side in a very intimate look at her life
and at her experiences in conservative media. Again, not a lot
of people write like this or not a lot of people in conserv
I think it's a little weird that he's doing the book review like
but maybe it's not weird cuz he has he has extra evidence that
she didn't have or he's he's like a corroborating source. I wish
he maybe he'll do a tweet. Maybe there's a tweet or >> for
me to write like this. Not a lot of people are willing to tell
you that when they were under contract to produce this many videos
at this amount of time that they felt like at some point they
were just paying the bills. They weren't actually, you know,
trying to be creative or engaging with content. Essentially,
they became a slave to the algorithm. And as somebody on the
content creator side of this, I definitely can relate to the
desire to produce more in order to be successful on these various
platforms that just demand more stuff from you and how you try
to hold on to what actually brought you to the dance. You try
to hold on to things that you care about, but oftent times, as
I've experienced myself, your failure to just go off of a headline
and just give the people what they want ends up damaging you
financially. Again, I relate to the idea that I could be significantly
more wealthy if I just pandered 100% of the time. And this is
something that Lauren struggled with. And it's different when
you actually have a child. >> Wait, aren't I programmed
to hate this person? I think so. >> To provide for and
you have all of those different various pressures. So again,
very interesting look at what people go through on this side
of the content creation spear. And also for me as somebody who,
you know, started my channel when I was older after I was age
26, for me who's somebody who still hangs out with the people
that I knew before I was an online person and I don't really
co-mingle all that much with other creators, it was interesting
>> my god, this guy yaps
>> to read somebody who was basically the opposite and
did everything in my opinion wrong in the opposite direction
and fully embraced the lifestyle and being around all these other
e celebrities, admittedly to her own detriment. So again, hard
recommend on this particular book. There will be links in the
description where you can get a copy of it. And again, it's something
that that I think will be interesting to a lot of people, but
especially if you're interested in the content creator side of
things and you like the innuendo and conspiracies related to
the feds.
Wait, wait, wait. Push, that's exactly it. He ends like every
little story as if he's about to get to like the actual important
thing and then it's another little story.
>> surveillance, how political activism is treated and
how somebody who is an idealistic young person can get beaten
down by the system. But that being said, of course, there is
a major thing that is going to take all of the headlines of this
particular book, and that is a couple of chapters that actually
describe an encounter, which by the way, Lauren is accusing Andrew
Tate oft. Make no mistake about it. And I want to go over those
particular chapters, those particular allegations, because I
know a lot of you just want to play the Super Mayor clip and
say that they're false allizations, as she would say, and not
facts. Alpha
Oh, cool. He's going to have some stuff. >> Say false alleations
and not facts. >> Now, I think it's important to >> false
alle be upfront and give you guys a full disclosure before I
get into these particular allegations, and that is the obvious.
I consider Lauren to be a friend of mine. She is one of the few
people from >> Oh. Oh, wait. Wait. They're friends. Does
Shawn know that he shouldn't be commenting on this? Guys, does
Shawn realize he shouldn't be commenting on this? They're friends.
That's like a I'm >> The internet world that I actually
invited as a guest to my wedding. And under normal circumstances,
if Lauren had told me what was in this book, the words that I
read, I would not press her for more information. I would not
demand documentation.
I would not ask for medical records, corresponding text messages,
or any of that stuff. under normal circumstances, a friend of
mine accusing somebody I don't know from a hole in the wall,
that would be good enough for me again in the context of a friendship.
And as for Andrew Tate, honestly, I genuinely find it depressing
that so many people on the right, especially those who preach
family values, would side with somebody and promote someone just
because he has a big following who calls himself a pimp and made
most of his money by getting girls into webcamming and by his
own accounts in multiple different various videos, use underhanded
tactics in order to do so. Again, you have a lot of people critical
of the adult film industry in my audience in conservative media.
And yet, this guy who made all of his money through adult films
and that particular industry. And no, Sean, you don't understand.
He converted to Islam. Actually, converted to Islam, that undoes
that. Okay?
Even if you made a ton of even if you sold a bunch of work, okay,
it's okay. He's he's Islamic now. He's he's Muslim. Mashah, brother.
and bringing women to a foreign country in order to make them
cam girls who again describes himself as a pimp. And for some
reason, this guy gets embraced. And that is something that I
absolutely do not care for. Now, to be clear, in the past, I
have defended Andrew Tate under certain circumstances. There
was a video or a whole campaign to get him booted off the internet,
and they interviewed a bunch of teachers who said that their
third graders were not listening to them because they were women,
and therefore he needed to be banned from the internet. And I
fully stand by the fact that that
>> Okay. Do you remember Do you remember when we were like,
"Oh, he's finally gotten to it. He's actually still not finally
gotten to the important part of this video." This guy, he talked
about like, "Oh, sometimes I have to decide between, you know,
following my morals or trying to make money, right?" And just,
"Brother, why did you make a 3minute video into a 30-minute video
here? What is happening?"
Those teachers were ridicul. >> Here's the information
I got. Here's why I trust Lauren Southern. Here's like a little
announcement about my conflict. She came to my wedding. I'm I'm
a good friend of hers, right? But I've looked at the information
and I think this is reasonable and I put my weight behind it.
Boom. Done.
If they were real, the news media using them as an example of
why somebody should be removed from the internet was absurd.
And I'm not going to change my opinion on that because again,
in the context of that particular conversation, even if I don't
care for somebody, I think that is a very underhanded way to
remove somebody from the internet. That being said, conservative
media should not be embracing this guy. Red Pillars, they want
to embrace him. That's totally on them. But it is not conservative
to promote a who of course talks about luring in women and has
a bunch of different various accusations. Again, >> he
like literally is is openly duplicitous, right? He openly talks
about how he lies to women and steals from people like tries
to he basically just ruins lives to get money for himself. Like
that alone is bad against him. Many of which he has basically
admitted to or said something very similar was what he was doing
at the time. Now, because of those biases that again I openly
admit to, I knew that in order for me to cover this book in order
for me to actually go over these chapters, I needed absolutely
everything, all the supporting information and whatnot. And essentially,
I had to treat it if the reverse was true and what it would take
for me to believe accusations against somebody that I knew. So,
basically, I had a little role rehearsal and then I ended up
having to press for all this different various information. And
now, let's get into the meat and potatoes of the allegations.
So, first of all, they are in fact 7 years old. They back to
an alleged meeting that was set up with Lauren and a bunch of
other people that she was working with. >> Rawhead Rick,
I know. Uh Masterson claims that Andrew Tate stole his whole
flow though as I don't know if you know that they like called
in. He was like a fan or whatever and he Masterson thinks like
basically Andrew Tate just stole like his old persona. The old
like Masterson ultra misogynist persona >> at the time
that was supposedly to find this guy in Romania that was going
to be an investor into a new media group. And apparently the
>> Masterson is also I don't want to malign. Okay, he's
also ultra misogynist. There's just like an ultra extra ultra
misogynist caricature as well that he played sometimes. Okay,
I don't want to take any away from anything away from from ultra
misogyny when he's actually being himself. Okay, >> the
guy was a big fan of Lauren in particular. So they flew out to
Romania where Tate was at the time. And by the way, I've lined
up the timeline to check if he actually had the place in Romania
at the time that these allegations occurred. and they were going
to meet him to discuss again a potential business investment.
However, this was later revealed to be a farce according to messages
that I have seen from Tate's own war room after the fact. That
being said, they end up having the meeting. It doesn't really
seem to be going anywhere. It's not really all that interesting.
But later on, when Lauren's back at the hotel, she receives a
call saying that they want to have another meeting, however,
specifically with her to discuss business terms. And Lauren,
being the naive 22-year-old woman at the time, ends up going
to the second meeting under the guise of she's the person who
concealed the deal. And then quickly, they are moved from said
meeting to a bar. She also says that she was consistently told
that the rest of her group would be joining them. And eventually,
she has some drinks. And there may be some implications in this
particular story that maybe one of the drinks was drugged or
she drank too much. It's honestly not 100% clear. I'm just going
off the text right here. And I actually didn't ask or press for
the idea. Uh, I think it's incredibly clear from the text that
she's implying she was drugged.
Like I understand it's not an overt
declar, but it is incredibly clear from the text that she's saying
she's probably trying to say, "I believe I was drugged. I didn't
take a talk screen. I can't prove it, but I believe I was drugged."
>> Yeah. That this was the case when I was talking to her.
So again, I'm just throwing that out there of what's described
versus what you might actually find out to be reality at a later
point in time. Now, again, that's just my speculation, but here's
what it's based on. Despite having only one shot and still working
on my vodka soda, I found myself feeling surprisingly intoxicated.
Usually, only beer hit me this quickly. I paid no mind as I was
fast distracted by conversation. Maybe it was the vibe of the
club or just the fact that I was coming off as a stereotypically
fun, carefree blonde. But Donnie, who had been friendly to me
enough as we bantered about politics and online culture, suddenly
seemed to take my relaxed demeter as a green light. Or perhaps
it was one of the edgy jokes I tossed out. Either way, his tone
shifted and he was far more candid now. Now, Lauren goes on to
explain how they start talking about crypto schemes. This isn't
really germaine to what we're talking about in this video, but
yeah, again, these chapters you can check for yourself. And then
they end up back in the hotel. Now, Lauren, of course, being
hyperritical of herself, ends up saying that she voluntarily
got into bed with Andrew Tate, voluntarily kissed him. However,
she didn't want to go further and Tate used some form of strangulation
or asphixxia. Again, I don't know what the technical term, choking
or whatever in order to force her into the encounter. And of
course, she claims that she fought back in these particular allegations.
She said no repeatedly. However, she was choked to the point
of near unconsciousness more than once, but unknown number of
times, and the encounter occurred, and she kind of leaves it
there at the chapter in the book. You can read it for yourself.
There's actually a moment where she says something to the effect
of what happened is obvious, or what I'm saying is obvious, and
she doesn't want to get into it any further. Now, again, this
comes from chapter 11 of her book. It is entitled Confessions,
and it reads as follows. It was kind of my fault. I can trace
every moment I had the opportunity to turn things around right
up until the point where everything went wrong. The truth is,
I could have said no to the strange business meeting overseas,
at least until I had more information. And I could have refused
to go to the club until my friends were with me. I could have
turned down the drinks. With whatever little sense I had left,
I could have said no to what I foolishly thought was a harmless
cuddle when I had no intention of going any further. But honestly,
I'm not sure it would have mattered at that point. This wasn't
a >> I honestly can't see it. >> Of mixed signals
or intoxicated blurred lines, I fought back. I was pleading.
I just didn't realize there was a point of no return, a moment
where my voice would no longer have any power. I'd rather not
give a detailed account, so I'll keep it simple. He carried me
back to my hotel room and asked me to sleep beside him. I said
yes. I was incredibly intoxicated and some part of me could >> look
carried me back to my the hotel room and asked me to sleep beside
him. So she was actually carried back. Yeah. >> Myself
that because he was Tommy's friend, he wasn't particularly dangerous.
It was a poor decision, but it happened. He kissed me. I wasn't
expecting it and I wasn't looking for it, but I kissed him back
briefly and then told him I wanted to sleep. I was extraordinarily
tired. He wanted to go further. I said no very clearly multiple
times and tried to pull his hands off of me. He put his arm around
my neck and began strangling me unconscious. I tried to fight
back. He repeatedly strangled me every time. I regained enough
consciousness to pull out his arms. I prefer not to share the
rest. It's pretty obvious. There's no way. Dude, this Queen with
a Q guy literally sent me the same tweet. Okay, the exact same
tweet that Queman did within like 4 seconds of each other. He
Quimman DM'd Dumi
with a K and then Queen with a Q put it in chat within 4 seconds
of each other. That's like actually disturbing to me. That's
very weird. Okay, that's
>> I'll show you the tweet. I listen now. I'm not reading
it anymore. Uh I'll we can make some jokes. Okay, I I don't get
like insane, but listen. Milo Milo is a bad person, but he can
be funny. Okay, very dark. Very dark humor. Look me in the eye
and tell me the girl who said yes to this said no to Andrew Tate.
Incredibly low resolution photo too. What the h
will not retweet. Will not retweet but got to show it. Okay.
It's funny. It's funny unfortunately. God because I have to go
into journalism mode. This was not good enough for me again.
7 years ago. Andrew Tate has all these alleations against him
now. So obviously people are going to have a lot of problems
with this. They're obviously going to agree with her own assessment
that she is to blame for certain steps that she put herself in
that situation by engaging in. However, one of the things that
I find incredible. Okay, real quick. Obviously, I don't have
to say that you could find people attractive for very different
reasons and obviously saying no even to an attractive person.
I obviously there's a whole bunch of things that are just obvious
there. I don't have to say any of them. Just live your lives.
Again, >> interesting is that of course because I pressed
for more information, I was able to receive medical records from
within the week of the encounter. And according to these medical
records, Lauren basically described the exact same sequence of
events. In fact, unfortunately for me, there's actually a more
detailed description of the events that went down on that night
again within a week of her alleging that they occurred. And I
didn't really So, a lot of people would would look at this and
say, well, that's not evidence of rape, right? Just because she
gave her testimony from that time, that's not evidence of rape.
But it is quite compelling that she tells an extremely similar
story in terms of the coercion and physical violence methods
used by Andrew Tate to assault somebody as women who have like
valid and credible allegations against him and cases pending
currently right that from like different times that she could
not have possibly known about. That is something when those things
line up like that that should make you go oh wait there's something
to this there's something to this there's something to this right
that's why that's important. I know a lot of people say, "Well,
that's not proof of anything." Well, it's not direct proof, but
it is evidence. >> You need to read that, but for journalistic
purposes, I ended up having to see that. And I can tell you that
the allegations that she made back in 2018 that are in this report
that are documented at the time are very similar to what was
released publicly by Vice years after what she said. So, the
MO looks to be the same. And again, that is strong evidence in
her favor. And it is a report at the time. It's documented in
medical records, and I've seen them for myself. And by the way,
I think that she has sent them to another media outlet that will
probably publish more of them because I'm not a journalist. I'm
not going to publish her personal medical records because I don't
know what I should be redacting versus what I shouldn't redact.
And honestly, I feel a little bit weird releasing personal detailed
medical information of somebody that I consider a friend. Now,
look, I'm no fan of Vice Media, but the fact is they have this
January 4th, 2023 piece, which is nearly 5 years after Lauren
would allege in those medical documents an assault by Tate using
the method of strangulation. And wouldn't you know it, in these
allegations, we have two women and one of them says they were
repeatedly strangled by Andrew Tate. And again, we also have
other articles where these women say that they witnessed him
strangling other people repeatedly. So, this is very interesting
that Lauren's allegation that is documented at the time is sort
of like corroborated by a different person that she would have
never known saying the same thing. >> Wow. Comes up. I
say it and then he says it. Wow. >> To vice 5 years later.
Now again, you want to say coincidence. you want to say actually
Lauren is clairvoyant. She's just happens to be a psychic. That's
on you. But to me, I just find this parallel incredibly interesting.
In addition to that, in the book, Lauren describes a war room
exchange that actually has a back and forth where they end up
admitting that the meeting was in fact a force. I've seen screenshots
of this war room meeting. And again, it seems pretty weird, pretty
unusual that in and around this time 7 years ago, before a lot
of the allegations against Tate were made public in the first
place, that so many details of Lauren's account that appear in
the notes of her medical report end up lining up with what's
in the war room. In addition to that, there was also a text message
exchange between Lauren and Tate where she describes that this
was not okay. I >> mean, Andrew and Lauren both felt as
natural. What? I find me Lauren Southern saying that on the record
somewhere. I I that's an absurd thing to say. And by the way,
I will even go further, okay? It's kind of like It's kind of
like I'm going to do an analogy, okay? It's kind of like the
Ethan Klein thing. All right? Just because you think is natural
or something you're a woman doesn't mean people can you. All
right? That's not a like just because you have like really really
anti-woman views doesn't mean you're a fair target. Okay? That
you you don't get to be a fair in the world that can make you
a fair target. He's B. Yeah, obviously. But there are people
saying the stuff. Yeah. I don't know if you guys realize this.
Okay. Sometimes chatters can say something and it will like give
me a chance to riff like something I want to say anyway.
And whether or not they're being serious doesn't matter. Okay.
I I hope you understand that whether or not they're being serious,
I can still say the thing I was going to say anyway, right? Gotcha.
Okay. >> This was not acceptable behavior. And the back
and forth at least acknowledges that something happened. Although
I'm sure Mr. Tate would say that his defense is in fact consent.
Now look, I know a lot of you are going to say this is not something
that should be adjudicated online in a YouTube video and I 100%
agree with that. I hope and I'm optimistic that Lauren takes
whatever legal avenues that she has in order to back up and substantiate
these alleges
for these allegations. She might have a case for like a I don't
even know if she'd have a case for a civil suit somewhere at
this point. Like it's been she might have a case for a civil
suit, but would it have to be a civil suit in Romania?
Actually, she might have a good shot in Romania now. I don't
think they like them very much there. But, uh, criminally, I'm
not sure she's got like it would be very difficult to pursue
something here, right? I do think that if she can help the existing
cases or provide like, you know, credible testimony to existing
cases that I would like to see her do so. She said she she'll
do as much. So, however, there's going to be a lot of additional
people that say that Lauren is doing this for the money in order
to have some kind of teaser related to her book create buzz about
it. However, she's actually releasing the chapters that detail
these allegations for free. And I'm going to try to link them
in the description if you want to read the account for yourself.
And in fact, here she says that explicitly in the additional
note parenthesis upon completion of this manuscript. I finally
decided to leave this chapter in the book. At first, I wrote
it just to process my own emotions, convincing myself no one
would ever read it. For a while, I thought about replacing parts
with dramatized anonymized scenes in order to avoid drawing too
much attention. But after a lot of reflection, I've realized
I'm done with cowardice. If I'm going to do an honest book, I'll
do it right. And this is a big part of my story. Why now, though?
Is a very valid question. You know, a lot of people think, "Oh,
you're just deciding to tell us this story in your book." To
make sales. What about the legal cases? Can't believe you didn't
help earlier. Now, Lauren responds to these likely questions
with the following. I should start by debunking some misconceptions
here. First, I will be releasing all of the chapters relevant
to Tate for free. It's not about money, and frankly, I'd rather
not give people another excuse to project their own twisted motivations
on to me. Not that I'm too worried about the opinions of anyone
who thinks human trafficking and scamming men out of their life
savings is some kind of noble vocation. Second, I've always >> All right,
I don't need we don't need necessarily like a second reading
of this stuff. Get on to his final commentary on it. >> Lauren
has assisted where she can to the >> We've got one more
chapter here about when she tells people about it after the fact,
after it happened. So, we'll check out this uh last chapter once
we finish >> the extent where she got up to the line where
she wanted to maintain her anonymity. And I'm absolutely happy
to hear that. And presumably, she would be more open to assisting
based on the idea that she quite literally published these allegations
in a book. She's releasing that stuff for free online for everybody
to read so she doesn't make money off of those specific allegations.
And since the book is published under her name, anonymity is
no longer a concern. Plus, the overall tone and tenor of this
particular chapter is that she's not going to be a coward anymore.
She's not going to hide this. She's not going to cover this up.
She is going to bring it out into the sunlight. So, yeah, I think
Lauren is heading in the right direction, if you allow me to
speculate just a little bit. But I do want to point out that
it is very unusual that she is making these allegations about
a meeting that occurred when Andrew Tate wasn't even that famous.
In fact, Lauren was probably in terms of internet fame more famous
than him. Despite the fact that I believe he had been on Big
Brother UK at this time and been booted off and of course that
he was a kickboxer at some point in time, she was just more famous
in this world. And this is all documented. >> Her using
the story's promotion is fine. She can't get any reparations
for these cases. So, it makes sense for her. Um, yeah. I mean,
it's like she already explained like her rationale. Even if her
rationale was I'm going to publish this because even though I
kept it secret, like I just want the I want to make what I can
off of this. Even if that was her like actual rationale, as long
as she's not lying about the things she's putting in the book,
right? As long as the chapter is still truthful, I wouldn't really
have a problem with it. It's really about how truthful the chapter
is. And again, she's got contemporaneous evidence that she went
to some authority, you know, filed a police filed a police report
or tried to file a police report with the UK police, talked to
like a medical like a a women's hospital and and put like an
an allegation on the record there or basically what she said
had happened on the record there, right? And it sort of backs
up some other cases like that's about what she could do. She's
she's trying to do it trying to make things work. How many sales
is that cracking? Um I don't know how well her book's going to
do. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I think she's got
a lot of burned bridges and it it kind of sucks, but she just
wants to seems like a lot of her the last video she did, the
video out in the woods with the article from that seems like
she more just wants like closure on being in the space and she's
kind of okay with the fact that she's not going to do it right.
It seemed like she did the video in the woods and then I think
Lauren Chen reached out to her and she got like she was like,
"Oh, I'll try this again with Tennet."
That seems to have gone, right? Obviously. And then and then
she's publishing this book. It seems like she's I would imagine
she seems to be done, but maybe maybe not. Maybe this is about
Yeah, hard to say. At the time through the medical reports and
the meeting specifically is referenced in these war room logs.
And I've seen all of this documentation, reviewed all of this
documentation for myself, which again is an uncomfortable position
for me to be in to demand all these different receipts and pieces
of documentation from someone I consider to be a friend. After
reading about a
>> Tommy Robinson did not witness it, Aquilla. No, Tommy
Robinson witnessed like that they were together, but Tommy Robinson
actually came out and explicitly said, "Well, I witnessed them
being loveydovey the next day." I'll play that video shortly.
Encounter that probably is not something that she wanted to discuss
with me in the first place. That being said, I'm sure there will
be a counterveailing explanation about the Matrix, about intelligence
agencies being involved. What about the nation of Israel? What
does it have to do with this particular case? In my opinion,
those are all ridiculous. It's a bit absurd that she would end
up documenting this in all these different various ways. Years
before Tate was famous, years before it was broadly known that
these accusations end up surrounding him. But again, people are
going to believe what they want to believe when it comes to this
case. And we will just have to examine the evidence as it trickles
out as I'm hopeful it does come out and it does come forward.
And a lot of people by the way in conservative media have invested
themselves in the whole Tate, you know, personality or whatever
you want to call it. So I understand that they're going to go
full offense mode. And in fact, Lauren describes maybe an army
of like paid hit pieces that will likely come out against her
that of course will do absolutely everything to paint her as
a money grubbing absolute non-respectable woman or whatever you
want to say. But again, this is actually a small section of this
book. I'm highlighting it because obviously if I didn't talk
about it, if I didn't press for information and I promoted all
the other interesting chapters around the book, a lot of you
would call me out and deservedly so. I press for information
because a lot of you will call me out and deservedly so and documentation
for the same reason. But again, I actually find the rest of the
story much more interesting. I find the pressures of being in
conservative media, feeding the algorithm, meeting people who
are behind the scenes, not at all what they seem, not at all
what they portrayed publicly, and of course, the repeated and
constant betrayal from people that you thought were your friends.
Now, with all that being said, I want to know what you guys think
about this particular book, if you're actually going to get a
copy of it. Okay. All right. Well, that's uh that's Sean's video.
Haw was right the whole time. All right. All right. Okay, we're
moving forward. I think we'll play the Tommy Robinson clip next.
So, this is from 2022.
See when this is I think this is from 2022.
This is January 2023, but there was stuff in Jan, it was right
at the end of 202 2022. So, there's a tweet that goes with this
as well where the CN guy, this Ken guy who was the cameraman,
he's mentioned the story. He says, "Andrew Tate showed me his
webcam room where he forces women against their will to make
and assaulted someone close to me both in the same day." So,
he was running his CAM business back then in 2018 and yeah, the
Rob guy or the Ken guy was saying um he's a total piece of
but Tommy Robinson came out like a few days later and actually
put out like a response to this. So, Tommy put the story out
in a secretly recorded phone call with George, something I did
not want to be shared to the world. I think this is Ken again.
Yeah, it is Ken again. Okay. I was blackmailed by Joe who threatened
to throw me in jail which he said he had the power to do linking
me somehow with Darren Osborne and the police he was working
with. I really don't want to get into other stuff. Okay, so let's
>> but I also know Halen Robertson works with and is operative
for home not hate as are many people. Now Kayen Robertson actually
detailed when he visited this house in 2018. Now this is where
it gets dark cuz this isn't new. Kalin's put this post out. This
is where you see how this is planned. Cuz Kayn Robertson,
Nick Lols, the leader of Home, actually contacted me with allegations
he was putting forward about me four four five months ago. Okay.
One of these
was that that Andrew Tate had a woman in 2018. So this has been
planned. It's been going on behind the scenes. This isn't fluke
that he's popped up with this allegation now. Yeah. Hope. So,
it sounds like
the somebody told the hope not hate person that Andrew Tate did
this and they didn't publish that right away and now he's now
Tommy Robinson is going well they've been planning this. I dude
uh just because he mentioned the allegation that doesn't mean
it's planned. That doesn't mean it's like some conspiracy. That
just means people knew about it or I don't know. That seems wild
to me that you just say oh this is a planned conspiracy because
they didn't publicly make the allegation back when they first
mentioned it. They like mentioned it, somebody brought it to
me or something. That happens with a lot of things. Things will
go around behind the scenes in some scene, right? They allegations
of certain kinds will be known for a long time. Diddy Cosby,
right? There are assault allegations or allegations against both
of them. They are known. They're like sort of open secrets for
a long time before they end up coming out. >> You're in
the middle of all, okay, creating sources, planning it. When
he sent allegations to me, he put allegations to me. Some of
them were ludicrous aloc allegations. Okay. And he said he was
running all these al >> Tommy. How can you support a Muslim?
Better question. Your hero is Tommy. How can you support a Muslim
who raped the white woman? I thought that Isn't that your entire
brand, bro?
Muslim men are going to rap white women and we have to stop this
from happening. Isn't that literally what you're all about? And
you're you're out here defending.
It's We're in Bizarro World now. What >> stories about
me? But you've seen so when when hope not hate were working with
Kayn Robertson and forcing him to work against me. Ken Robinson
was my cameraman. The only reason why him and this female I'm
not going to name her. They create these sources to pump the
headlines. You only get the headlines. You don't get the story.
Yeah. You just get the headlines and defame people and slander
people and destroy people's names. Now I traveled out to Romania
with Kalin and with this female. We went to see Andrew Tay. We
spent time at his house. Yes. He did show us the webcam business.
Yes, he did. Yeah.
>> Kaden's wording is that where women are forced, we don't
know that. Yeah. Everyone is innocent until proven guilty. Everyone
to all the >> Well, I would imagine end of 2022, Kellyn
has probably seen the like Hustler University, right? Or like
talks about making these women do it that
everyone should be viewed as innocent to prove it. >> Now,
the female in question
I stay in the hotel. She was in the room next door. In the morning,
the doors open. Andrew takes Ben in the room next door. She's
kissing him on the door, stalking him on the door as I come out
of my room. I witnessed that. I saw that. Yeah. We go down. We
get >> So, this would be the I guess primary piece of evidence,
maybe the the primary piece of testimony in Tate's favor is that
Oh, actually, despite what she said about being upset about it,
and I don't know if she it doesn't seem like she answered that
necessarily, although it could be in the next chapter. We'll
see. We'll see. I would imagine she answers this clip or answers
to this clip in some way. because you kind of can't totally ignore
it existing. I'm guessing it's in the >> She's texting
him the whole time. She spent the next few days working with
me in the UK. She's texting him the whole time. I actually believe
she flew back out to see him. So Kayn is saying the operator
for Hope Not Hate. Hope not Hate have been working. >> So
I will say she did mention texting him because he was texting
her like being angry at her. Right. >> We're big tech to
get rid of Andrew Tate which hasn't worked. Yeah. Kayn is saying
that that lady cuz the only lady who's with us has beened all.
>> Yeah, we'll get to it. >> Messages message. Now
look at this. >> Steven Lennon aka Tommy Robinson continues
to defend alleged Andrew Tate. Yet he has known about Tate's
predatory behavior for years. Not only that, but he's helped
cover it up. The full truth will come out soon. # Tommy is available
for partisan from partisan books. Tate has recently converted
to Islam. Judging by his comments, endorsed the Taliban. Scoffed
education for girls in some country. The way he treats women
endorse guitar seems to me he's described to
Some people make this argument back in 2022.
That's uh
up been funny. >> I've been covering from covering from
with the truth. They're going to lie to you. Okay. Unless unless
this lady was in the room and decided to snob the face of Andrew
Tate on his on his hotel room door as she was leaving, get in
the car, message him, and plan to go back out and see him. Yeah.
Unless that's what's happened. Okay. cuz I witnessed it with
>> cuz I I'll never take somebody seriously with this accent.
By the way, I don't know which flavor of bonger this is, but
I'll never take this guy seriously.
I I'll take I'll let his his testimony like stand on its own
here or whatever and see if Lauren addresses it or if she says
it doesn't hap didn't happen or what. But um the accent is just
goofy. >> My own eyes. So when you start seeing the media
pumped and you start seeing the news stories making claims of
from 2018 cuz this left-wing activist journalist who gets paid
blackmailed by government shady organizations in order to do
this again you have to watch my expose a documentary which proves
all of this proves how they operate. What I'm saying to you is
if you see these allegations against as I've said I can't I can't
downplay every other allegation cuz I don't know. Yeah. But what
I do know is that I saw this girl kissing Andrew Tate on his
hotel room door on that morning and continued messaging him and
I believe went back out to see him. So this is a lie. This is
a lie that's now being pushed. So I've seen one lie and what
you get is opportunists,
people who think they'll get money. Now the girl in question
that we're talking about is also listen to this one. You
>> I know. Sorry man. I suppose I know it's 4:00 in the
morning. >> Okay, I can already tell who the voice is.
Why is he like acting like he has the voice in? Hold on. Let's
>> I've just got off the phone to Kin for an hour. Yeah.
How much have they told you about Hope? Not hate. >> Not
much. What? >> You're aware they've been meeting with them
regularly? >> I I've met Joe too before. >> Yeah.
Like I know I know that and >> bro, he's not even remotely
obstruct. Why is the picture obstructed?
The voice is obvious. met with them before >> continually
met with them when you was doing your borderless documentary.
Hope not flew out to Italy to meet them. >> I don't know
what they were talking about, but for the most part, like I think
they're like they're just afraid of them. From what I've been
told, it's like they're like, "Oh, they're kind of blackmailing
us, like hang out with us or or else we're going to get you guys
arrested or whatever." And so they >> She's also was a
right-wing journalist who was working with Hope Not Hate behind
the scenes getting money off them. Now she was banned from America
and Canada. Yeah. She had a ban not letting them in. She turned
she went against all of us. She made up allegations against me.
Yeah. In order with an agreement for home I hate to get a visa
to get to be allowed into the country she's banned from. She's
now allowed into those countries. So who knows whether she'll
play ball with this latest that they're about to spread by Andrew
Tay. Who knows if she'll play ball. You may see her making allegations.
What I'm telling you is the facts of what I saw in 2018. And
that tweet that he's put out is a lie. >> Okay. All right.
Now, I wanted to listen. I want to discount that entirely based
on his accent and oh, he's a like drug addicted, alcohol abusing
loser. I didn't want to focus on too much of that. Okay. Let's
uh I got a I got a thing on what is it? Ken Robinson, right?
Got a thing on him.
Maybe maybe I will finish real quick. I'll finish the last chapter
here. We'll see we'll see some of the fallout. Let's go back
to the Lauren Southern article and let's finish it so we can
get back and we'll we'll see the Kalen article after this. There's
some of his tweets that went out. I think that's what Lauren
was talking about when she said there were like weird activists
using the story to like try to sell like do their own thing that
were like trying to weaponize her story against people and she
didn't like that. So, so far Milo is given the most compelling
evidence against Lauren to be honest. Yeah, we saw it. We saw
it. It's it's okay. Okay. Or the fact he said she was banned
from her home country. Maybe. What? Oh, are you saying Tommy?
Yeah, Tommy's. Although he might he might have said that saying
like her home country was where her husband and her kid were,
right? Okay. Chapter 12. Nowhere Land. Only a few opening paragraphs
are connected to the incident in the previous in the previous
chapters. I told him, Tommy, and the boys what happened almost
immediately after getting into the cab to the airport. Andrew
walked me to the hotel exit where Tommy, Callen, and George were
waiting in the car, gave me a hug, and as soon as the taxi door
slammed shut behind me, I blurted it out. I said it in a weird
manic laughter. You won't believe what the just happened kind
of way. Oh, sorry. You won't believe what the just happened kind
of way. But I was damn clear. The boys laughed, too, until Tommy
looked at me and said, "You serious, mate?" And I said, "Yeah."
And got into the darker details. The laughter lingered for a
bit like they were waiting for the psych, waiting for the punchline
that never came. We Googled Tate on the flight home, curious
to learn more about who he really was. Apparently, he'd had a
brief brush with Big F with fame on Big Brother before being
removed from his house or from the house after a video surfaced
showing him hitting a woman with a belt. The more I scrolled,
the more foolish I felt having ended up in the situation. But
by that point, it didn't matter. It was just one more absurdity
in a world full of them. Another drop in the pan of chaos we
were all too used to. So just including the sections that from
other chapters that talk about this story. Chapter 18, retirement
party opening about opening about personal life has been cut.
You may recognize some of the this content from a video which
I ironically called the whole truth in which I attempted to address
some of the this drama without mentioning anything in regard
to Andrew Tate. Regarding the Tate incident aware, I was married,
pregnant, and my borderless documentary was about to be published.
Naturally, my husband wanted me to visit his family in Australia
to share the exciting news. The only issue was that since my
last trip there, the one where we first met, the Australian government
had added me to a list called VACCU,
Vacu. Essentially, it's a flag on your passport for character
reasons typically reserved for people convicted of criminal activities,
those involved in terrorism or apparently politically incorrect
YouTubers. In 2019, I applied for a general visitor visa only
to be rejected. Even if we settled in Canada, Australia was still
a part of my husband's life and that he couldn't let go of. I
knew I had to find a way in. For months, I sent inquiries and
called the government uh government helplines, but got nowhere.
My husband visited a home a few times, but I had to stay behind,
pregnant, emotional, and increasingly isolated. I was less active
online, and I hoped that would be thea that would help my case,
but I wasn't ready to leave public life completely. Maybe I'd
still write the occasional article or return to filmmaking once
my son and hopefully more children were older. The rejections
wore me down. Being separated from my husband during such a vulnerable
time made the stakes feel heavier with each passing month. It
became increasingly clear as long as I maintained a media presence,
the door to Australia would remain shut. I eventually chose to
step away from public life entirely. After border list was released,
I published a retirement article and sent it along with a new
visa request to the government. The response confirmed I still
failed the character test due to my previous conduct and content
that may have incited Discord. But my retirement had worked.
They explicitly cited it along with the personal nature of the
visit as the reason my application wouldn't be refused. It was
clear stepping away from politics wasn't just a choice. it was
the cost of entry. The message ended with a chilling warning.
Any future controversy could result in the ban, and this note
on my record would count heavily against me. So, in the end,
it wasn't a conviction or burnout that ended my career. It was
a government mandate. I always believed Western democracies respected
free speech, even when the views expressed were provocative or
unpopular. Mine certainly were, but I never imagined they'd be
grounds for exile. It was a slow, disorienting unraveling of
everything I thought I understood about the free world. the notion
that authoritarian regimes punish descent no longer held. I came
to see that power that power protects itself no matter the flag
it flies.
Um, I feel like there's probably something going on here where
that's how she sees it. There has to be like a personification
or like an intent to the thing, but it's probably just like,
oh, this person said like W or something online. Um,
yeah, they're like a clear white supremacist. They go to other
countries and talk about white supremacy and try to like rabble
rouse. Yeah, we don't really want them here. Right. It unfortunately,
and it's weird for a nationalist to think this, it's like, wouldn't
she be okay with denying people based on being from like Muslim
countries? Shouldn't Wouldn't she be okay with like a Muslim
ban? Shouldn't she in that same way be like okay with
that? Shouldn't really be enough to ban you in a free speech
country. Well, I mean, I think the countries probably reserve
the rights to the right to do what they want, right? I don't
think they should ban speech in their country, but if they just
have a reason to believe you'd be a member of their country,
participate in their country. I think they kind of do reserve
the right. It sucks that um that she like couldn't see your kid
obviously, right?
>> It's not a free speech country. Australia is not really
a free speech country. No, it's not like a free speech like um
I remember the crackdowns on their co stuff. The crackdowns on
their co went like nuts. You guys remember that? I think they
had pretty crazy crackdowns on CO stuff if I remember correctly
in Australia. Anyway,
uh the good guys I believed in as a child were just stories we
told ourselves. And once I let go of that illusion, the sting
of losing my political voice began to fade. By the way, I'd still
like probably, you know, protest or be upset about that or be
frustrated that were the case. I think she should be allowed
in, but I'm just like I don't know.
I feel like it's weird as a nationalist to be like, "No, you
have to accept me in even though you you feel like I wouldn't
be a good fit, a culture fit for your country,
>> Doesn't that seem that's like her argument? You're not
a culture fit for my country." Seems like Australia looked at
her and went, "You're not a culture fit for our country." I feel
like you almost certainly have to just go, "Yeah, that's you
know, that's fair."
>> We had heaps of rallies recently that got laws passed.
Jesus. All right. Outside the ruins of that world, I was finally
building something real. Oh, sorry. Sorry. we and once I let
go of that illusion that the good guys were in charge, the sting
of losing my political voice began to fade. Outside the ruins
of that world, I was finally building something real. But just
as I was preparing to publish my retirement letter and wrap up
Borderless, the ghost of that old world came knocking. One of
them was Milo Yiannopoulos, a previous colleague known much for
uh known as much for comment controversy as for commentary. He
began sending me strange messages. Apparently, he had gotten
into some dispute with my former film crew, who had just moved
on to work with other high-profile figures like Alex Jones, who
had since moved on, sorry, to work with people like Alex Jones.
They knew I was stepping away and had wished me well. I had little
idea that what Calin and George had been up to since we filmed
Borderless the year before, but Milo was working on some kind
of expose about them, and he wanted me in the middle of it. It
was exactly the kind of drama I was trying to leave behind. These
so-called investigations rarely had anything to do with real
political reform. More often, they were just personal grudges
or friend or enemy financed hit jobs dressed up as journalism.
Hit pieces and public cancellations never tell the whole story.
In this climate, false accusations blur the lines so much that
the real predators can hide in plain sight. While decent people
often get destroyed, not because they're guilty, but because
they're bad at the game. I told Milo as much, explaining my decision
to leave politics and the complications surrounding my visa.
He remained polite, but there was an unmistakable undercurrent
of menace in his tone that I didn't appreciate. He already wasn't
impressed with me for declining to do a tour of Australia with
him. And I somewhat I was somewhat concerned he was the kind
of guy who didn't take rejection well. One second. I just need
to grab water here. I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Oh my god.
All right. Once I published my resignation article in the summer
of 2019, it wasn't long before Milo published an article of his
own. To my surprise, it seemed to focus as much on my reputation
as it did my videographers.
Maybe even more so given how much of it was based on fabrications
about my life. He claimed that I had been a secret leftist all
along, working to dismantle the right-wing throughout my entire
career, citing absurd evidence like me allegedly professing love
for Alexandria Kaziocortez in private and collaborating with
Antifa adjacent activists.
Well, he got me at one point at least. One point at least. She's
hot. What can I say? Okay. As for my supposed Antifa connections,
Milo included a short secret recording that Tommy Robinson had
made of me in which I admit to meeting with a far-left pressure
group called Hope Not Hate. Of course, the clip conveniently
left out the fact that I was meeting with them to secretly record
the group James O'Keeffe style. The meeting was uneventful and
the audio was unusable.
Tommy already knew that story or already knew the story. Then
out of the blue, he called me one day asking me to repeat it.
I It got so strange I kept asking if he was recording the call.
He swore he wouldn't do something like that. Not long after,
I heard that very call heavily edited without any context played
in a documentary he made. Poetic irony. I attempt to make my
undercover debut and instead I end up with a cameo in someone
else's propaganda film. Lesson learned, God. I should have laughed
it off. The more time I spend outside of the political world,
the more embarrassed I am by how seriously I once took these
allegations.
It's not even that they were unfounded, though they were. It's
even that even though or sorry, it's that the whole thing feels
so childish. The secret leftist as if we all don't have at least
one at the dinner table on holidays. Who cares if I were? What
does that even mean? Are we still in high school? Why are any
of us even talking like this? Yet back then, I did care, and
it was devastating. What stunk my ego the most was Milo's claim
that I had never written my own content. He alleged that I traded
for video ideas and scripts to climb the political ladder. A
classic trope against women in politics and media. Almost poetic
given my past criticisms of feminism, a cosmic joke at my expense.
Of course, it had to unfold this way. The accusation was so ridiculous,
it should have been obvious to anyone with a shred of common
sense. No one needs to sleep with someone for ghostritten content,
especially when most of my work consisted of man on the street
videos. The whole notion was bafflingly stupid. I've been clear.
I was no trad saint. If that had been the allegation, fair enough.
But I wasn't guilty of what Milo claimed. And it was scandal.
It was scandal he it was scandal. If it was scandal he was after,
I was hardly the best target. Plenty of my male peers in the
dissident base were hiring escorts, cheating, using drugs, even
committing crimes. It didn't escape me that many of the loudest
amplifiers of his article were the ones most guilty of that behavior.
And not coincidentally, men I'd rejected, either romantically
or professionally. And yes, I can already hear the finger wagging.
Feminist this, feminist that. I didn't flinch when people called
me a racist for suggesting immigration rates might be a tad too
high. And I'm certainly not losing sleep over being called a
feminist for pointing out the glaring hypocrisy in right-wing
media around gender. Jesus. All right. You can see it in the
podcast that dominate right-wing spaces. panels of men dragging
in groups of Only Fans girls, shaming and humiliating them for
their pasts, pretending to represent modern womenhood.
Sorry, modern womanhood.
There's no female equivalent on the right. No podcast where men
are lined up and held to account for their own behavior or being
the main drivers of Only Fans. Instead, you get endless monologues
from self-styled truth tellers insisting that men are supposed
to sleep around while women must remain chased. As if that's
not completely antithetical to the conservative, religious, and
family values the space generally claims to champion. And that's
just what played out in public. Behind the scenes, the culture
shaped by those beliefs was a mess. The same men building platforms
to shame women for having sex outside of marriage were often
the ones most aggressively trying to sleep with them. It was
a rigged game. If a woman said yes, she was proof she was proof
women had no virtue. If they said no, they'd sulk, badmouth her,
and or quietly blacklist her. I saw the cycle play out constantly
in my life and in the lives of women around me. It would have
been funny if it weren't so bleak. Everyone involved seemed trapped
in a warped, self-defeating performance. Honestly, at least Andrew
Tate was publicly shameless about being a pimp and embracing
double standards. It's a more honest take than pretending anything
of this was about morals. Even beyond the podcast circuit, in
the more polished professional world, there's no female equivalent
to someone like Donald Trump or Elon Musk.
A woman with endless baby daddies would never be taken seriously
within the Republican party. When you build a system where men
are granted limitless moral indulgences while women face social
destruction for far less, you don't create a culture of virtue,
you create a culture of madness. It's gaslighting at an industrial
scale. And the truth is, you couldn't even fix it by making the
standards go both ways because there was never any real standards
to begin with. Just uh farle
it's far.
But hold on, it's far, right? Why are these videos so long? which
means excessive excessively or bias
or pronunciation. Thank you. We are looking at how to pronounce
this word and more
>> I actually won't listen to that anymore. 34 seconds.
Thank you. >> Speech modification.com.
>> Ferrisa like Pharisees. That's what I thought so. Or
sorry, that's what I thought. Me. Pharisea. Just pheriseaical
sneering dressed up as moral clarity like the Pharisees. Like
the guys who Jesus. Okay. All right. It's a dog whistle. I knew
I knew this whole thing would be anti-Israel somehow. Okay. Is
there just a Google thing? Usually there is. Not for this word.
Yeah. This was the world I operated in for a decade. And it made
me worse at relationships, not better. Had I followed the examples
my Savior of the Western world peers set, I may have actually
become the character Milo spun of me. using my people for their
bodies, treating intimacy like a transaction. But even at the
height of my career, I was still a romantic at heart, looking
for a life partner. I made my dating mistakes the way our ancestors
intended, awkwardly, emotionally, and without a single app or
ghostwriting agreement in sight. Still, I somehow became a lightning
rod for internet morality panic. A friend joked that I should
get a shirt like the one like one from the movie Easy. It felt
uh easy. A
what? Easy. E. This is a movie. Okay. It felt fitting only in
this version. It wasn't high school rumors spread about teenagers.
It was a middle-aged man pounding out an 11,000word think 11,000word
think piece about my dating life like it was Watergate. At the
end, I'm a human at the end of the day. Sorry, I'm a human. I
enjoyed a good relationship as much as the next person. I made
poor choices that sometimes led to heartbreak. But Milo's accusations
weren't rooted in reality. They were projections. Ironically,
I think they mostly came because I was trying to walk away from
the very people who I'd followed away from healthier paths. I'd
seen the behind the curtain, participated to a degree, and then
decided it wasn't for me. I wanted out. I wanted to heal, to
clear my head, and to see if I could still build something real,
a family. But walking away isn't easy when people know what you've
seen. The darker side of that dissident world doesn't like loose
ends. You don't get to dip a toe in, then pull back. Oops, don't
really like that. But don't worry, I won't tell anyone what they're
all really up to or what you're all up to. That made that made
me both a complicit coward and a threat. The worst possible place
to be and exactly why I was hit with a reputational nuke. At
first, most dismissed the article as nonsense. But as I stayed
silent, even skeptics started to believe it. I had my reasons,
my visa, but I couldn't share them. The traction was faster than
I expected. Thousands upon thousands of Twitter notifications
sharing the article, spreading like wildfire. It felt orchestrated,
like someone was pulling the strings. In the piece, Milo pointed
to various men who claimed I had taken advantage of them for
business purposes. Of course, he never named any of these men.
While I knew the story was false, I struggled to determine how
many were entirely fabricated versus how many were just guys
in the space nursing a rejection wound or a personal gripe. Eventually,
a friend tipped me off. Andrew Tate had been circulating the
story in his private group, The War Room, a collection of men
who were paid to promote and amplify his content. He had openly
and proudly told them regarding the men on record with Milo,
"Everyone in the space knows it was me. Secrets out. Oh well.
He also shared a chat with another content creator who is apparently
involved in the piece. Paul Joseph Watson.
PJW makes his appearance. I think they dated. I think that's
I don't know if she disputes that even. So Milo basically me
too Lauren. That's crazy. Milo's a hateful guy. Very hateful
guy. All right. Oh, did the music pause? It did indeed. There
we go. Okay. In the conversation, Taint Taint Tate sent a voice
note that appeared to outline some sort of strategy.
Watson responded is still accurate though. Watson responded seemingly
in agreement. Sounds like a plan. I later discovered that just
before Milo's article dropped. Watson shared my retirement announcement
on his Telegram, writing, "What type of young woman with a hu
what type of young woman with a huge audience of male incels
jerking off with one hand and throwing money at her with the
o is going to
I don't know. I haven't watched a PJW video in so long, but I
feel like the smarmyiness is kind of it's kind of getting there.
It's kind of hitting.
Some would say she's retiring for the sake of marriage and having
kids. I'm sorry, but I just don't buy it. If I were a cynical
person, I'd say something sinister is about to come out that
will shock the conservative world. And this retirement is a manufactured
exit to avoid something embarrassing and dirty. I wouldn't put
it past a woman who falsely accused me of to lie about why she's
retiring. Uh, he is British, but I can't do British, so I'm just
trying to do smarmy. Okay. He's like very very smarmy in his
cadence. Why do I think that sounds? I don't know. Apparently,
it sounds
take Supreme's word for it on the accents. I was baffled.
I had never made any accusation of the sword against Watson.
It was a pure fabrication. And in reality, I was retiring for
the sake of my family and children. Paul, along with the other
associates of Tate, immediately amplified the article as soon
as it was released. Later, despite offering his initial condolences,
Tommy Robinson would make his own video claiming a woman he knew
was going to make false allegations, including falsely stating,
"I traveled back to Romania to see Tate again." He lied about
many things, both directly and by omission. Not once did he mention
the very first words I said to him in the cab the next morning.
I was devastated. He could have simply claimed ignorance and
about what happened that night. Instead, he chose to actively
lie. For a long time, I tried to understand why. What could possibly
motivate someone to do something like that? As far as I remember,
the last time I saw Tommy was in the hotel hallway after we'd
finished an interview about my UK ban. He was chasing me down
the corridor, urging me to come back in his room to do some.
I had no interest in returning to the spiral that began when
he first introduced it to me at the club in the UK. I said I
wouldn't be going down that road again. I walked away. I can
only assume that the that encounter has something to do with
his animosity toward me now. Okay. Well, okay. So, Tommy offered
her coke. She said, "No, thank you." And that's what she thinks
it's about. I It could have Why would he bring you around? I
don't know. H Lauren did not take a bump, right? To the spiral
that began when he first introduced to me at the club. At a club
in the UK. At the club in the UK. Oh, wait. No, she is. She did
take a bump. What? He was chasing me down the corridor, urging
me to come back to his room and do some I had no intro interest
in returning to the spiral that began when he first introduced
it to me at the club in the UK. I said I wouldn't be going down
that road again. I walked away. I can only assume Oh, Jesus.
I wasn't like processing as I read. Damn.
Lauren Southern was on Coke. Crazy.
But perhaps it wasn't just personal bitterness. Maybe it was
something worse. Self-preservation. After all, what kind of damage
would it do to Tommy's brand built on exposing Muslim grooming
gangs if it ever came to light that he once he that the once
bright he once sorry he once brought a young woman to a compound
run by a self-p profofessed Muslim pimp while high out of his
mind and she was assaulted on that very trip. In his mind, maybe
protecting his image meant making me the problem. And maybe like
so many others in that world, he told himself whatever story
he needed to to feel like a good guy. While the public assumed
the only reason these men turned on me was the accusations must
be true. I saw their motivations clearly. A message was being
sent to me. A narrative was being carefully crafted. One with
a clear objective. Lauren is not trustworthy. Lauren uses men
for Lauren falsely accuses men of rape. The reason she retired
is because it's all true. And there was one man who stood to
benefit most from the smear campaign. The same man openly bragging
about his role in Milo's peace. Andrew Tate. Worse, the eventual
war room leaks I received from a friend suggested that the entire
Romanian business meeting had lar had likely been a setup. In
the leaked messages, Tate laughed with war room members about
the idea that any real investment plan had ever existed. Do pimps
give girls money? He mocked. We didn't invest a penny. Dropped
her at the hotel, invited her for steak, she came. Then the club,
she came. Then the house, she came. Of course, he conveniently
left out the part where I never returned to his house. In reality,
I was carried back to my hotel room. Did Tommy know it was a
setup the whole time? Was I trafficked? What the That's uh something
I was thinking about is like if he was actually a fan of her
content or something? It's entirely possible he, you know, offered
money to the people cuz like they never really invested in in
media in that way, right? I don't think they ever did. Anyway,
I'm sure that's a like a real honest question. The more of the
story I unraveled, the stranger it all became. Andrew was slowly
gaining followers online and then I realized he had DM me a year
before we ever met. At the time, I didn't know who he was. I
didn't connect the dots when Tommy introduced us. Reading the
messages back now, they have the just had the energy of a throwaway
fan interaction. He felt like one of thousands of small accounts
that messaged me back then. Hardly any followers, nothing that
stood out. In those days, I interacted with my audience constantly.
I had no concept of how dangerous it can be when you don't know
who you're talking to.
Letting people get close, letting them feel like they own some
part of you. I'd send kind, thoughtful email replies to fans
only for them to morph into yearslong one-sided schizophrenic
relationships that slowly wore me down. That openness stopped
being safe. He exchanged a few messages or we exchanged a few
messages where Andrew cheered on my activism. I replied kindly,
even made a quip about a funny tweet I'd seen on his page. But
when the conversation shifted and he asked if I lived in England,
I stopped responding. Questions like that were always a subtle
bid to hang out. Like, no, I'm not going to visit you, random
person on the internet. It's the Fentes clip. What am I supposed
to meet up with you in real life? I don't know you. I don't know
anything about you. You want me to come to your cabin in the
woods? The wrong with you. What is wrong with you? Absolute just
huge brain blast. Okay. The the mind meld from Lauren Southern
and Nick Fentes. Same reaction. He found sorry, but apparently
he found other ways to get together through mutual connections
and faux business meetings. I agonized over all of this. How
intentional was it? How much of it was planned? Even now, I don't
know. At that point, what haunted me most was the question of
whether Milo was paid to write the article. But frankly, I couldn't
think of at least a halfozen pe or sorry, I could think of at
least a half dozen people who would jump at the chance to ruin
me. Milo himself included. Just writing that sentence makes me
feel like I've been living in an alternate universe Gossip Girl
with significantly less attractive characters, a bunch of Mchavelian
nerds. There were clearly many conversations going on behind
the scenes about what my future or lack thereof would be in the
movement. I knew too much about them all. Still, I couldn't believe
the smear campaign had begun before I had even spoken a word
about Tate's criminal activities. And I couldn't believe how
naive I had to had been to think that my silence and complicity
in this coverup would protect me. But when you operate like the
Tate brothers, you live in a constant state of paranoia, playing
whack-a-ole with perceived threats before they m even materialize.
At any given moment, you're haunted by your past. Ironically,
uh your past at any given moment, you're haunted by your past.
Ironically, often creating the very future you fear. The entire
episode disturbed me to my core. To their credit, their plan
worked. They got their results. They psychologically broke me.
I never wanted to face these people again. Even if Andrew wasn't
actively paying for it, he was actively a part of creating and
promoting the article. Andrew had been plotting to position himself
as a hero of the right-wing media for a while. He'd been reaching
out and building as many connections as possible with figures
in the media sphere, flying them out to his compound in Romania,
giving them donation. Okay, so he did do it with other people.
Never mind. Giving them donations, gathering information on them.
My public profile was much bigger than his at the time. I held
significant influence over the distant right-wing audience. For
him to break into that space, he would need to eliminate any
potential threats, especially a threat like me, who could turn
my loyal audience against him before he'd even managed to get
his brand going. I wouldn't put all these pieces together for
a while, but at the time, all I knew was that my audience was
gone. Now,
aside from a handful of fans and friends I personally knew, my
most dedicated political followers had already brand branded
me a traitor and a believing I had vanished before the full force
of these allegations hit, knowing what was coming. Although it
would strike still take some time before he was able to properly
enter the right-wing media space, I watched from afar as his
public profile grew bit by bit. Strangely, seemingly inorganic
interviews began to emerge with personalities he had encountered
in my former arena, appearing with increasing frequency. I was
one of very few watching closely then. I'm not sure anyone else
saw the repeated stories about him seemingly amplified by bots,
his early failed attempts to manufacture fame. He was dedicated.
I'll give him that. And eventually, he got the formula right.
Damn. Now, you might be asking yourself, why didn't I just sue
Milo for defamation? Get some extra cash for my political retirement
and clear my name. The truth is that the general public, those
who don't live in the media or online world, have a profoundly
skewed perception of how defamation laws actually work. In reality,
defamation law is largely designed to pro protect the wealthy.
It's not meant for the average person and certainly not for mid-tier
internet celebrities like me. Take my Wikipedia page for example.
It has never represented me accurately. It was a carefully curated
hit piece managed by anonymous activists who despised me. Even
Larry Sanger, Wikipedia's co-founder, had warned that the site
had become an activist controlled narrative machine. But correcting
the record wasn't an option. Wikipedia isn't a publisher. It's
a platform where anonymous editors shape public perception, often
with no oversight. So, I will say I'm reading I'm reading a lot
of this like fairly uncritically just to get the story, just
to get the facts. There are some things here that I'm like, well,
I need more evidence on this. I need more evidence on that. I
do see how
like I I don't think any of these narratives or ideas are unreasonable.
So, I don't want to like act like I don't believe them at all.
I just think um there are a lot of sort of throwaway things,
the Wikipedia stuff. I can see why there'd be like lots of reasons.
But that makes me think in my mind when I read this stuff,
I become almost most more certain that she's retiring,
right? Because I think she probably knows this and if she were
just trying to write this to get her career back and come back
and like talk about all this, right? I don't think she'd put
these things in here that like people can go, "Well, wait, do
you have any proof for this? Wait, you think like Andrew Tate
was like conspiring against you? Wait, you think like Andrew
Tate was conspiring to take out other right-wingers? Wait, like
you think that there was like you're being gangstalked on Wikipedia?
Like I I could see a lot of this stuff basically being pushed
back against, but I think because she's doing this is like uh
I'm out of here. So here's what happened. She did say when Sish
Adam interviewed her that she had consulted lawyers about Wikipedia.
That was two plus years ago. Okay. Yeah. I'm just I'm looking
at this and I'm like I think she's including all of this stuff
because she's just like, "Yeah, I don't I don't care. People
cannot believe me on this is what I think. She's not doing the
like airtight I'm uh she's not doing like an airtight thing.
You know what I mean? That she's meant to respond to or or get
criticism on. Okay. To this day, one of the opening paragraphs
of my page still falsely states that I was demonetized from YouTube
and banned from GoFundMe. Neither of which happened or ever happened.
But truth isn't a requirement for Wikipedia. I believe her parents
got banned from GoFundMe or her parents GoFundMe got like cancelled
or something, right? Isn't that what happened? And I yeah, I'd
never seen her be demonetized from YouTube. But truth isn't a
requirement for Wikipedia. What matters is what a handful of
dedicated editors decide is the official story. Wikipedia itself
couldn't be held accountable anyway. And tracking down the individual
editors would require a Norwich or a Norwich which order just
to uncover their identities, assuming they weren't scattered
across different jurisdictions where legal action would be impossible.
Even if I pursued a case, I'd need a six-figure retainer just
to get started. While suing someone like Milo for defamation
wouldn't come with the same hurdles on go uh as going on after
Wikipedia, it would still involve the same costs. Not to mention
that once you're classified as a public figure, the press is
granted significant leeway to publish whatever opinions they
choose about you. The internet is a dangerous place and these
aren't lessons taught in school. They're ones I learned firsthand.
Although credit where credit is due to the few teachers who warned
us not to use Wikipedia as a source and even more so to those
who encouraged a healthy skepticism in all media. At the end
of the day, I couldn't respond to the allegations even if I wanted
to. It felt unjust, but I accepted it as a cost of moving from
on from my old life to a new one. I stopped looking. I didn't
care anymore. My real life needed me, and it was time to move
on. At least that's what I told myself. But deep down, I did
care. My soul achd. I felt betrayed, not just by the online world,
but by the very people I'd risked everything for. When we talk
about parasocial relationships, it's usually for fans who are
looking into a celebrity's life. What we don't discuss as much
is the parasocial bond creators developed with their audience.
I felt a sense of ownership over them. I believe they owed me
loyalty. I had sacrificed so much for them, lost a part of my
soul for them, faced imprisonment for them, put my life on the
line for them. But the truth is, they never owed me anything.
They were never mine to begin with. I had built a parasocial
relationship with them just as much as they had with me. And
in many ways, I was the one who mistook their attention for something
deeper and something personal. I wanted their loyalty, but I
should have asked myself, loyalty to what? a version of me they
had built in their heads or the real me who had never really
been the person they imagined in the first place. I sank into
a deep depression. Everything I had built had been lost. I watched
people I previously called friends mock and speculate about my
life. The same accounts professing their love for me days earlier
were now cheering on my demise. I blamed everyone but myself.
The situation was messed up. There's no doubt about that. But
I wasn't letting myself or I wasn't setting myself up for success
by refusing to see my own choices had led me here. I had sold
my soul. Enjoying the praise of people who don't truly know you
is a dangerous game because they don't know you. Because they
don't know you. They can be made into to believe anything about
you. And it's not their job to dig deeper to find out who you
really are. They don't owe you that. Maybe what they owe them
that maybe what they owe themselves though is to stop caring
so much about the drama of the famous because in the end that
obsession is as much of a perversion of the mind as my own obsession
with their thoughts. At the end of the day, I got on the fame
train and rode it until it was going at speeds that threatened
to kill me before I jumped off. And then I was angry at the train
for taking me so far. I may not have I may not have known exactly
what I was getting into, but no one forced me onto the train.
I wasn't a helpless passenger. I wanted the ride. I thrived on
the speed and attention and sense of purpose it gave me. I say
I jumped off, but really the train went off the rails. It stopped
being fun. I like to focus on the crash, on my victimhood, but
the part that's hardest to admit, I was angry the train had stopped
serving me. Good ending. It's a tremendously sad story. Um I
feel very sad reading it. Oh man, Captain Cappy Pants. That's
funny that she at the end just is like probably the thing she's
most bitter about is that she she was complicit. She was doing
what she wanted to do and she was just mad it stopped working
out. Right. That's that's literally the ending. Completely cuts
against what you just said, which is kind of funny. She's like
literally chastising herself at the end of this for not criticizing
the right things. You have to keep reassuring us that you feel
sad and that think this is bad. Uh, okay. Uh,
I that's commentary. Noah Tannon Bomb. That is your last name.
Tannon Bomb. Eh,
grifting plus accepted to scam her followers. Okay. Anyway, that's
uh that's it for that stuff. There is one more thing on Ken that
I was going to pull up. This is just an article on him calling
him a liar. And then I don't know if we go back to like I wonder
what Andrew Wilson's doing because this guy was not that tweet.
Is it this tweet called like Hillary Crowder? Apparently Hillary
Crowder and and Lauren are friends. Hold on. Oh no, don't do
that. What is this? It was only after Lauren and I forged a solid
friendship that she opened up to me about being violently assaulted
by Andrew Tate. I'm not saying this is to show I'm in the know,
but because I think it's important others understand how deeply
private she was. I pray her vulnerability and courage is a balm
to those living with the pain of a similar trauma and that ultimately
her willingness to share the truth with humility and graciousness
will help bring justice to all of his victims. Uh, repeatedly
strangle me every time I regain enough conscious to pull at his
arms. I prefer not to share the rest. It's pretty obvious. Yeah,
right. What a croc of hor. Okay. Andrew Wilson doing his same
things. Hillary Crowder is the exwife of Steven Crowder. Louder
with Crowder. Steven Crowder.
You know that guy. That dude. All right. All right. Okay. I joined
Collins. I don't know if I'm going to do Collins. I just joined
Collins. People want to join the stream or whatever later. Oh
boy. Okay. From here, I've got the Khaled article. And then,
do I have other videos on this? I don't know if I have any other
videos on this to be honest with you. I think we go to Epstein
stuff after this. I think
>> Creger, thank you for the 17 months. Let's go. W huge
W. Okay, I'll read this Kin article. I think it's it's probably
worth reading. Did I move it over? I did. Five years ago, so
2020.
All right,
>> I don't know exactly where this fits in the timeline.
I was just thinking um I believe this has quite a few of the
tweets about Lauren. Let's see here. Callum mentions nothing
about the connections to the well wellunded American Islamophobia
industry cahend
this very soon. Hold on. I'm just looking around. Oh, these aren't
even his tweets. Hold on. Looking for After yesterday's exchange
about the alleged redemption of Kalen Rob. Here is an excellent
piece from Louise Raw author for MSR online and his performances
and his performances to the highest bidder. Lies and a videotape.
The publicly denies the of a young woman who was retraumatized
when she read it. all to score political points, disgusting,
vile, anti-feminist behavior that's no better than the far right.
The author has no interest in ethics or making the world a better
place. So, this is him probably like vaguely talking about this
>> You're genuinely sick in the head, Louise. Sick. I never
compared myself to Mandela and never joked about
as a survivor myself. You're a vile grifter using victims as
a weapon to score points. You put her pain in a headline with
a question mark, Louise, which led to a retraumatization. Sick.
So, at some point he says this is about Andrew Tate, right? These
people go back and forth arguing about this stuff. You know very
well my paragraph on the allegation was deleted by lawyers because
you refused to confirm it on the record. You joked about it drunk
in a crowded bar, telling anyone who would listen about your
friend's blah blah blah pain. Oh, friend's pain. There are witnesses
to that. As a survivor, I wanted to expose the even though I
knew I knew I'd be attacked even further by the far right. And
you read this piece a year ago and didn't make the fake allegations.
Then you just complained about my portrayal of you attacking
me who your farright chums threaten and abuse by trying to compare
me to them. St. Calvin the well-paid martyr as these are this
is like a very personal fight on Twitter. At some point in this
he does pull out the yeah
I've confirmed this many times before there in the aftermath
of what he did and took her to the hospital. You apologist and
the police. Did you go there too? Uh yep and the hospital. It
is unclear when or where this alleged crime occurred, but Robertson
alludes to it being on UK soil after making the claim pictured
below that British police were unable to arrest an alleged due
to him residing in Romania, an EU member state. Bearing in mind
that the UK will still was still part of the European Union at
the time, Robertson made these claims at by line at by line festival
and because of this European arrest warrants because of this
European arrest warrants to apprehend criminals residing in other
member states were available to UK law enforcement agencies.
I did not lie about him once and he wasn't arrested by British
police because he resides in Romania. Have you done questioning?
Have you he done questioning victims or is this going to carry
on all night? So, apparently the drunk allegations are when he
was drinking and at a bar he made these allegations to a reporter
of some kind. Uh for context as to why we're drilling down to
into UK police involvement, we've considered the following timeline.
The alleged victim of the was given a lifetime ban from entering
the UK in 2018 after pulling a stunt earlier the same year in
Luton with Robertson to offend the Muslim community and incite
further racial t tensions. Andrew Tate was in the UK in March
and August 2019. Harassing Mike Stuchberry Stberry at his home
in support of Yaxley Lennon's well documented videtta against
Stukeberry. So just had these sent to me while waiting for police.
Banging on her door was Andrew Tate, kickboxer, and someone else.
So apparently Andrew Tate has been turning up at my house again
taking pictures and driving off. Given that the path of Tatan
Southern could not have crossed in the UK immediately before
or after she announced her retirement from public life in June
2019, the alleged crime is either a historical one where UK police
could have made an arrest regardless of the accused residing
outside of the UK or occurred in another country where local
police could have made an arrest. So, she didn't go to the Romanian
authorities. Uh it's it's a little interesting to me that this
was so well documented back in 2018 and people really didn't
put the pieces together. Like you would think you'd think some
like kind of provocators would have pulled this stuff back up,
right? Or so well documented in 2020
that like when Andrew Tate was rising that people would have
brought this back up. But I guess this is one of those things
where it's like if Lauren Southern doesn't want to talk about
it. If you if you go to her on the record to talk about it, right,
she tells you to
>> No. Uh no, no, no. Nick's he was not a goon for this
guy. Hold on. The pictures of Andrew Tate here. He's got like
a Lamborghini or something, right? He's in a really nice car.
It's 2018. He was already like a multi-millionaire at this point.
I don't know why he was in the UK doing this, but in 2018 he
was like a multi-millionaire with a compound in Bugattis and
in Romania. So anyway,
okay, let's just finish reading this. Given that the past Okay,
even they couldn't yet Robertson's claim but why Southern suddenly
announced her retirement from the toxic environment they both
inhabited appears to insinuate this occurred more recently than
her last UK visit in 2018. Furthermore, the man Ken named on
Twitter is different is a different man to the one he named at
the by line of f festival to an attendee which was unable to
be published in the morning star article after the person he
said it was was unwilling to put it in writing to the legal team
probably due to very real fears of personal safety and Robertson
was unwilling to go on the record. Okay, so nobody wanted to
talk about it and the person he was naming didn't want to go
on the record either. >> Okay, got it. Got it. Kellen also
stated that he went to the hospital with the victim and helped
report to the police for alluding to this alleged crime being
committed in the UK. What? So now the the reason this story probably
seems weird is that they flew back the next day, right? I think
they flew back the next day. So they could have gone to things
in the UK to to talk about this. Manella named on Twitter as
the is a world champion kickboxer mixed martial artist. He's
not well known a well-known figure on the far right, but does
have a long stand or does have long-standing connections to Yaxi
Lenin from his time residing in Luton prior to relocating to
Romania. He uses Alvoudan Twitter account where he offers online
courses for men on how to become alpha males, brags about how
he is a pimp to the girls who work in his webcam business, and
he is no and is no stranger to controversy regarding his odious
views of women and his arrogant self-aggulation.
Tate was removed from the UK reality show Big Brother in 2016
after homophobic and racist tweets from him surfaced alongside
the video footage of him hitting an ex-girlfriend with a belt.
Both participants have since confirmed this was consensual and
part of roleplay they indulged in. The woman involved displayed
a tattoo stating tape property. To be clear, Andrew Tate is not
somebody resisting hate defense in any way. Editors note, "We
think he is a racist misogynist pratt and we have got him suspended
from Twitter on several occasions. However, despite his deplorable
views, we cannot assume there's any truth in the accusations
made against him by Calin. There are very serious allegations
which need addressing, not only for the man publicly accused
on social media and the man privately accused at the by festival,
for but for the safety of all women who come into contact with
genuine perpetrators who has had not been who have not yet been
brought to justice for alleged rape. We are unaware at this point
of Agitate is aware of these allegations made about him by Ken,
but will be forwarding them to his legal team. Oof.
>> So, it does seem like different people have used this
allegation or talked about it in a lot of different ways. So,
Ken, if you have any decency, put up a shut up. Lauren Southern,
for those who care, returned to public life recently, posting
a detailed tit fortat response on Twitter regarding the stinging
allegations made by Milo Yiannopoulos about Robertson's comments
last year and her involvement in the whole tedious business.
Southern made it very clear why she left the movement. The truth
was was less lurid, but much more decent. I have found a husband
and started a family. And for once, the bulk of these accusations
do not come from the left. They come from the right. Might be
worth checking this article out as well. Is this Tommy writing?
No, it's um it's it's a different author. I I believe the author
is Hold on. This is resisting hate. So, this would be like a
left-wing group that's reporting on like Tommy Robinson and they're
Callen Robinson
by resisting hate member. This just is pre previously written
about this guy. My name is pronounced Kalin Robertson. his descent
into farright extremism and former employment with rebel media
and Steven Yaxley Lennon aka Tommy Robinson. Oh, this is Tommy
Robinson. Oh, I I probably read that before and I just wasn't
connecting. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I never met Ken Robertson.
Sober. Was this Tommy writing about him here? And just for good
measure, here's an extract from Yiannopoulos's rant last year
about Robertson. Resisting hate would normally give zero credence
to much of what disgrace Milo pontificates on, but that his assessment
here has been borne out by others. Plus, it confirms Robertson's
alleged excessive drinking habits, his inability to be discreet,
Wilst under the influence, and his raging need to be the center
of attention by bragging about his exploits in social settings.
If he doesn't like reporting on this, we just if he doesn't like
the reporting on this, we suggest he takes it up with the author
of that piece. So, this is from Milo's hit piece, I guess. I'll
read it. I've never met Kellen Robinson sober. He flew to Miami
in April 2018 to record an episode of the Milo Show. When the
camera started rolling, he gushed about his crush on Tommy Robinson,
and I caught a whiff of liquor. I took him for supper afterwards,
during which he down some red wine as I struggled to keep up
with his drinking. Robertson spent two days in Miami fredding
to me about his weight gain and asking for workout advice. Okay,
now we know Milo's lying. Nobody's ever asked Milo for workout
advice. Come on, bro. On first meeting, Ken is charming and insucient.
He gossip and cautiously about anyone and everyone and asks a
lot of prient questions, which makes for gripping dinner conversation.
He sounds like a possibly not gay alcoholic Milo instead of Milo
who is extremely gay and a drug addict, but they sound very similar
in a lot of other ways. Very interesting. You wouldn't notice
until the second or third day his tells. He struggles to make
eye contact for any length of time and carines abruptly between
halting physical affection and studied nonchalants after three
or four drinks. He's an ultra ultra cryparian holding for uh
holding forth on subjects of which he has little to no knowledge
or intellectual curiosity. But I can see why people enjoy his
company. A bottle of blues is all it takes, and you get hours
of salacious, loose-lipped gossip about anyone and everyone.
As he got progressively more inebriated over a seafood platter
at the Trump door golf course the day after the dinner, he confided
that he did not have sex with his boyfriend George more than
once a year and described himself as an alcoholic. I'd already
figured out at least one of those facts. A dysfunctional picture
was emerging. The more Robertson drinks, the more he begins to
So, he is actually gay. So, they there's another commonality.
There you go. He begins to brag about his sabotages and insider
status. With each gulp, his inner egoomaniac, amoral, and gloating,
further asserts itself. My editorial assistant, whom Robertson
did not know, was also in the restaurant with us, made recordings
of our conversations. It was obvious to all of us that Robertson
was unstable and untrustworthy. Textbook sociopath, concluded
my producer. Watch yourself and watch everything you say.
Wow. Wow. You don't see people dropping susant very much these
days. Damn. Wait, is Tommy Gate? No, his boyfriend George. This
is uh this is about not Tommy. It's about Ken. Callen Robertson,
the camera guy for Lauren. These farright people are actually
the worst people. Actual scum of the earth. Um yeah, sure. Milo's
funny though, unfortunately. Total piece of but very funny. All
right. I think that's basically it for this story. Uh maybe there
there could be like other interesting things on it, but I I'd
have to go and dig them up. Why are all these right-wing freaks
gay? I have no idea. I I don't know what's I don't know what's
going on there. Okay. I got no clue,